this is Jocko podcast number 355 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening so it was
about
2009 or 2010.
I think
and I'm in San Diego and that year in
San Diego whatever year this was the
80cc trials or in San Diego so this is
the championship of Jiu Jitsu of
submission grappling and you have to do
you have to get qualified to go there
and they have a bunch of competitions
all over the world and the North
American qualifier happen to be in San
Diego
so I went of course
and I brought my son with me
so I got my son with me and you know
he's like
seven or eight years old but you know he
trains all the time so he knows what's
up
and they announced you know who's next
up in this one mat and they go oh next
up is gonna be some guy blah blah blah
some guy
versus Jeff Glover and I was like I told
my son I looked at him I go hey
I go this guy we're going to that that
mat to watch this guy Jeff Glover I said
he's crazy
and so
we run over that mat we start watching
and sure enough
this guy Jeff Glover and I knew Jeff
Glover because I we started competing in
Jiu Jitsu around the same time as a
matter of fact I have a I have a a sheet
of paper that has the champions of like
uh
grappling games or one of these old
school Joe morier one of these
old-school Jiu Jitsu tournaments
and the first place winner of the white
belts is Jeff Glover the first place
winner of the blue belts is me and then
Dean Lister is like the purple belt or
something along those lines but it's
pretty cool right
so anyways Jeff Glover comes out and
what does he do he like
does donkey guard which means he
basically turns his back on his opponent
goes on all fours runs at the dude
backwards
and engages him and then 14 seconds
later he's got the guy and he'll look in
the guy taps
and my son who again he's like seven or
eight years old he looks at me and he
goes
when you said he was crazy I thought you
meant crazy ah I didn't know you meant
crazy
so that was it that was uh that was kind
of a a moment in that I really remember
about Jeff Glover and then luckily for
me and luckily for everyone in San Diego
Jeff Glover came down and actually
taught Jiu Jitsu at Victory MMA for five
years for five years we had Jeff Glover
here teaching uh Jeff Glover he ended up
you know he's done all kinds of stuff
he's the Pan Am champ 2005 the Pan Am
champ 2006 2007 Noki world champion 2008
nogi silver medalist 27 time champion of
grappler's quest maybe it's more at it's
But A Lot 27 times champion of
grappler's quest and we are uh super
stoked to have Jeff Glover here on the
podcast to talk to us tonight Jeff
what's happening
also with him is Pete letzos which who
you probably don't know you probably
don't know who Pete letsos is but that's
okay you might know who Pete the Greek
is Pete the Greek another Jiu Jitsu
Legend
uh
1999 and 2000 Pan Am third place as a
blue belt 2001 great Gracie Invitational
Champion 2002 Sao Paulo state champion
2003 Pan Am Champion purple belt got his
black belt in 2006. under the under the
The Crossing Gracie side of the family
and you know what that means Carlson
Gracie Jr uh 2006 Pete the Greek opened
his Academy up in Chicago
he's he's famous in the Jiu Jitsu World
featured in the book The Gracie way he's
without a doubt the best wrist Locker in
the world making sure that the world is
not ignoring that five percent of the
body
Pete the Greek thanks for coming down
man hey thank you sir thanks
Jeff so here we are two Jiu-Jitsu
Legends in the house nice for me you
know I love jiu jitsu
I love Jiu Jitsu and so it's nice for me
to come in here and just be able to talk
about jiu-jitu but let's talk about you
guys and and how you guys got started in
the game uh Jeff so so tell us a little
bit like where'd you grow up
would your parents what'd your parents
do
uh my mom was a nurse and my dad had all
kinds of different jobs and they uh
ended up in Santa Barbara which is where
I found Jujitsu like 16 I started you
were 16 when you started and everyone
thought I was like 12. yeah because you
still look like you're 16 now
yeah what what how did you get to the
gym what happened
um well Francia actually uh moved next
door to my mom's house him and his whole
Brazilian family there's like 12 of them
they all moved into a house together and
like next door neighbors yeah like right
there the same block that Bill Cooper
lived on
yeah Bill wasn't even in the scene yet
but he lived in that neighborhood and
was one of the kids but yeah frenzy up
so then what he came over and was like
you need to learn how to fight boy I
went over there to make friends you know
and knocked on their door that's kind of
how it was in that neighborhood you know
like it was a nice spot it was a nice
place to live and uh
yeah I knocked on the door he opened the
door and like he had a TV playing UFC in
the background what year is this I mean
this was like 1998. okay yeah 1998 or
nine and um yeah it was just super crazy
like he had you know the cauliflower the
shaved head it's intimidating you know
that you remember the first time you saw
a really good Grappler and the way that
the way their head just kind of looks
different you know in the ears
um so did he say like I teach Jiu Jitsu
you're like what is that karate like I
don't want to do karate that looks you
know I mean I didn't understand a word
he said for the first six months all I
know is he was just very persuasive and
was pulling and pushing me places and I
found myself on a mat with people trying
to choke me and it was awesome
and then how long was it before you were
like in the academy taking classes
like the first week that first week
after that first week I like told him I
was like dude I want to do what you do
how long did it did you realize the
power of Jiu Jitsu immediately were you
just like why is this happening it
didn't really it didn't like dawn on me
none of that none of that profound stuff
was Dawning on me it was just so cool to
have this like Mentor guy telling me
what to do that was like telling me to
do push-ups and yelling at me like you
know he would kick me if I didn't do the
calisthenics work he wanted me to do you
know like I'd never had that in my life
and I was like I didn't care what it was
doing if that dude was jumping off
Bridges I would have jumped off Bridges
but that dude Jiu Jitsu tournaments on
the weekend and push-ups during the week
so that's you know it was just really
nice yeah did he open that Academy
immediately this is by the way if
anybody wants to know this is Paragon
Jiu Jitsu this is uh this is Ricardo
frangia Miller yeah like epic instructor
and you know obviously he has Jeff
Glover under him has Bill Cooper under
him has the other Glover yeah Tyrone
Tyrone Glover so he's made a bunch of
just incredible uh Jiu Jitsu people yeah
he's still up there at Paragon yeah he
has a big Empire that he runs and
operates out of uh Ventura and all over
my my middle my middle daughter is now
part of the Paragon Empire because she
goes to slow yeah Chris Lovato he was he
was one of the first guys that came into
franzia's Jujitsu world with like really
good wrestling and I used to fight Chris
Lovato when I was like 17 16 17 18 I
would that was like one of the first
like men friends you would let me like
fight
saying and I got some good work out of
that dude is that where you started
developing good wrestling
yeah him and Tyrone you know Tyrone came
in was like all right all these
Brazilian names all these Judo names
that you have for these takedowns
there's wrestling names for those two
you know like double X that's that's
called that's not called bayana right
that's how they called it that's not
called bayana that's called double leg
you know and he's like can you and you
change levels when you do it too you
know just like wow bend over and grab it
like there's you know yeah and uh yeah
that was it I started wrestling early
early yeah yeah yeah your wrestling is
is like underrated right because people
you're so fluid on the map that people
might not recognize that and you're
you're freaking creativity on the mat is
ridiculous it's ridiculous and we'll get
into like where that came from but
before Pete yes sir how'd it go down
well first of all you're from shy town
right yes so tell us a little bit about
that what's going on where are you from
my dad my dad owned hot dog places my
dad was the first one to have a Euros in
Chicago so he'd put it on the spit and
and we basically would flip restaurants
we'd flip hot dog place they're not
little standards little like across the
street at The Malt Shop so basically
those type of place a little bit smaller
and um
so my dad would we'd go and find a place
you know we're Greek we'd find someone
struggling that could they'd open them
not know how to do it and we'd just take
it over and flip it you could either
flip it in a few months maybe a few
years but one that we kept was called
kings and queens and uh it was in Berwyn
which is right next to Chicago it's
right on the border and um there's a
karate place next to it so my dad my
dad's tough he's from Greece it's
parents left him at 13 years old he took
care of himself since 13. they brought
him to the United States at World War II
as soon as that was he was born in that
uh in that time so he's like born in
1942 they brought him over and his dad's
like you know what I'm out and he left
and his left him and so then he made it
to Chicago and he's a tough guy so he
always wanted like but he worked hard so
he never really worked out he's like I
never worked out I just worked and the
karate place next to the to the place
and my dad got his black belt and he
would just do private lessons with like
the master and all that and so my dad
would train me when I was born he had me
like at 40 years old and so he'd be on
his knees and fight me all the time and
make me tough and I don't know where he
learned that but it was like War
training so so I started doing that and
then um I went to the karate place but I
didn't like it I would just show up for
the belt promotion I'm like all these
kids are getting promoted I'll fight him
and then like they'd get promoted but
they have to fight me and
the guy's like look man you can't come
back you know you have to come to class
and um
I was good at floor hockey and baseball
and stuff and I found out that my cousin
was like the best ice hockey player his
name is Chris chelyo she's one of the
best ones he's in the NHL he lived in
San Diego
and um
one of the kids uh was getting bullied
so that dad's like no no we're gonna
teach you and so they brought me on the
ice hockey team and I beat up the bully
day one I was never that big but I was
ready to fight people for my friends and
uh
I really don't have to fight anyone but
it's just it's fun it keeps you strong
and
it's the next thing what happened next
so where did you do they brought me to
ice hockey so an ice hockey was cool but
I never really wanted to play Ice Hockey
they just want me there to beat up the
bullies so
so then bam I saw UFC it was like 1993
at my mom I live with my mom growing up
my dad went back to Greece and uh I'm
like I want to do I looked at my mom and
said that's what I want to do and she
looked at me he's like that's it you
should do and I was like the only mom in
history I was like that looks perfect so
we just watch it and um we moved around
so I went to a few high schools the last
high school I went to
um because we was called Montini and and
they were really strong wrestling
programs so you see like Jon Jones
wrestling coaches from there they have
like Izzy wrestling all these kids are
top-notch wrestlers and so I would go to
the restroom and fight them pretty much
I was like 14 15.
and I was able to do well against all of
them but I would never wrestle because
it was ice hockey season so then finally
one says one of the Gracies moved in
town and I couldn't drive yet
so then um my mom's like yeah my mom had
a heart attack I still can't drive my
mom had a heart attack at four teams I
took the car went to Gracie's and I met
Carlson Gracie Jr I'm like whoa I'm like
this is this guy's like he's one of them
and then he didn't like to drive so I
became his personal driver
and then when I would drive him people
want to kick my butt because I show up
with the coach you know I'm always with
them and then that's when I met Carlson
Carlson would bring Vitor and everyone I
was so happy I didn't even know there
were Jiu Jitsu tournaments I just
thought there was Pride Fighting and UFC
and then
should I join I just became one of them
I became the driver
just drove them everywhere and then
eventually eventually you went to Brazil
right yeah how far along was that wait
so then um there's a tournament going on
I lived in Ohio so Carlson Gracie Jr he
was my best friend he lived with me and
he lived with me and my mom in Chicago
he lived alone but you can't move from
Rio de Janeiro to Chicago it gets
depressing it's like I'm knocking on his
door because my job was to pick him up
and take him to class like people still
have that like a lot of Jitsu coaches
they love to other students come pick
them up hang out and take them to class
so
I'm knocking on the door and he's not
answering I kicked the door down I'm
like look come live with me and my mom
and then he lived with me and I started
getting really serious about Jiu Jitsu I
was about 16 at that point what year was
that around 96 somewhere around there 96
97. so now you're training freaking hard
hard so I'm his driver I show up to
every single class it's um Carlson
Gracie team so we always have people
from Brazil Carlson Gracie always come
visit us because O'Hare Airport's
International
so before things were different they
could stop I think they can still do
that but whenever they go to Brazil
wherever they'd always bring their team
and stop in Chicago and visit his son
and how to fight them and
I didn't even know there were
tournaments existed I'm like well these
these guys make a lot of money like no
one on my team was broke you just seen
Vitor coming eating metrics because you
didn't even eat food I was like Mom I
want to be like this guy my dad looked
at him he's like oh my dad didn't
understand so much because I didn't live
with him but um
my mom understood that's what I wanted
to do and so 110 behind me
and I never really had to pay for
training because when you train like the
way Jeff and I do
I first we start off cleaning them first
we start off usually is like training
dummies we help with privates we help
with everything so you know God bless
all that and I start training
shoot I end up in Brazil next thing you
know I tell I'm at the tournament in
Ohio so it's my first day of the purple
but I should go as a blue belt and
Carlson JR says look you're going as a
purple belt tomorrow I'm like oh yeah I
show up there and um I smash everyone I
do a couple over under moves and like I
smash a lot of pressure I beat everyone
and then a guy comes out of the out of
the crowd his name is Henry metamoros
he's back in the day he he fought
Rafael cadero and and the old Valley
tudo things and he comes out
and he's like I want to go against you
because I beat a Pedro sour guy he's
from Pedro Sauer
[Music]
and then I I beat him boom
and then how many hours a day were you
training no all day I would just pick
them up I was just there
Jeff it's a lifer Jeff how many hours a
day are you training once you started
training not as much as Pete yeah right
no way he came after Jeff came after
because I met on the map people in
Brazil and they Scotty and them yep and
then so I had a train that heard because
I wasn't accepted my my team destroyed
it fell apart and so then I met Scotty
and Scotty had all the information he
had to digital okay so hold on you got
you got Carlson Gracie team because a
bunch of people left to make Brazilian
top team right so I'm in this tournament
in Ohio and the coaches uh the the
referees Cristiano Marcelo he had he's
like the guy from crazy my top and he go
and he was coaching shoebox and he goes
tells the Carlson Jr if this guy if he
moved to Brazil no one will beat him
suddenly they said that about you yeah
he was a ref and I when I won that and
so then bam I stated
I say to Junior I said I need to go to
Brazil dude and he's like sure he's like
perfect he calls his mom and I show up
there in my backpack and I'm like what'd
you tell your mom I said I'm going my
mom was happy how old are you I'm about
20. okay my mom was happy and what year
is this
it's around two thousand
Jack okay going to show up there and I'm
and Junior's like my brother Carlson
crazy Jr he lived with me and stuff
we're like close like real close like me
and Jeff the mom never met me she and
she just gave me I said Beach because my
name in Portuguese like a dog like pit
bull she gives me a hug I give her a hug
we didn't know any I couldn't understand
anything I knew some swear words but um
so I show up she works at the gym
Carlson wife work at a gym 45 this is
Jiu Jitsu crazy so I walk over they take
me everywhere like this is Beach you
know don't mess with him and we meet all
the bikers they have all types of you
know mutual friends that they know us
they don't you know this is Pete
shoot
I was like it was great and and then um
yeah but I showed up to the gym like the
third day they asked me to teach class
because the team fell apart and I was
like whoa like I didn't come here for
this
so then I tell Carlson
I'm like look like I want to train hard
because they only had a few guys left
most the guys that stayed left somewhere
like the loyal guys but some of the guys
that no one wanted
it's like they didn't go with them
because no one wanted them
so I was like whoa
I'm like I can't stay here so did you
feel like it was like a political
scenario it was like a war it was like
show up to a war after your team just
got massacred and you're just like
they're like whoa so you what was it
that made you not want there was one guy
there there was a few left like so was
it that all the good guys left they all
left it was like two or three of us left
one of them was so tough
he was a biker a biker guy I think he
was like in a Hells Angel or something
he um yeah for sure he was he went back
to Brazilian topped him to beat all them
up and take them back he was hectic and
he was doing a great job of doing it but
he got in trouble and I don't know what
happened to him
but he was actually doing it he had one
guy at the end willing to go there and
beat them all up and take them back and
he was doing a good job of that but
didn't work out
things like that dude out of context the
house the whole idea of like one guy
going to another place beating people I
didn't know him I didn't know that oh
yeah Carlson best friend named pocket
rules son his name is Pakistan actually
I went through with Scotty Scotty's like
the American guy over there that films
everything everyone loves him but Scotty
always has money around so I show up to
the Brazilian top team at Scotty one day
it was like an enemy territory I was
like whoa I'm like I saw all these guys
it was in the
Bank of liborio has also worked for Bank
of Brazil so he hooked them up with they
had a country club where they trained he
was badass like I walked in there I was
like whoa there's like 80 hundred people
you seemed like I was like whoa and then
the guy in navajara he was the guy with
the tattoos my best friend there
well because he was the last one left he
comes up and right away
I'm in there he stops the whole train
because these guys are trying to sell us
stuff I'm with a bunch of American dudes
and the little guys like from Top teams
like oh buy this buy that I'm like what
I'm gonna buy a final top team nothing
and then nobody else sees me beats here
he's the only brother in the room
that'll fight with me against all you
guys he assume everyone will come back
to the Carlson racing team it got hectic
in there I was like yeah
and then he's like don't worry Pete I'm
like all right and we just stood there
and that was when I went to the top team
and then it was never the same after
that
um I could never join them so I went to
all the other schools Carl said look
I know you went there
he said you can't go there again you can
go anywhere else so then I went to every
other team I showed up Gracie buys
trained I lived in Oswaldo house I
trained Ted a day I went to every other
gym no one really liked me but they
respected Carlson like you would hear
like Gringo
I'm trying to hear green I'm like all
right the cost and Gracie I'm like oh
okay I know I need Portuguese but I knew
that that's what I mean it's about to
get heated and so Scotty like where's
people at every school he went to
everyone tried to murder you yeah and so
Scotty Scotty took all the videos of
everything and then like that's when
Glover is being built at that point this
is when Scotty's making videos like
ringworm and all that videos all the
stuff yeah dang fever oh that's right
Scotty got to make the videos because of
me because Carl's best friend was pakita
he was the guy that filmed like Carl's
best friend he's like hey what should
you do you should film so Pakistan
filmed everything so then they showed up
to the house they're like we don't like
your friend Scotty
films everything he's making all you
can't just show up to Brazil and film
everyone
like we don't like him they don't like
when you do that here literally yeah
back in the day dude because back in the
day it wasn't like now you know you can
go on BJJ Fanatics and just get like the
best moves of anyone because they're you
know you can go buy them but back in the
day you couldn't buy the best moves from
anyone because it was a secret inside
that Academy no because Hector because
Scotty was from healthgracy Health made
them nervous Health still makes people a
little nervous
but they didn't really care they're like
you know Scotty the Scotty guy gotta go
and I'm like they're like what do you
think of him in Brazil they talk like
that they talk like family what do you
think of Scotty I mean Scotty's like my
brother and then look at Pakistan what
do you think of Scotty he's like
Scotty's like my son so bam Scotty got
to film everything
at that point in time dude I remember
those movies back in the day they were
like gold at that point in time they're
like they're telling about this Glover
guy I'm hearing about these guys back in
the United States I didn't give a [__] I
was like no I'm in Brazil I'm here like
oh I don't care about anyone over there
I'm like I'm I was there on one thing it
was just a smash and like and do
whatever I needed to do just uh it was
the only one left on my team
and so uh Glover Glover was able to like
Scotty had a big part in Glover I'll
guarantee you like he's not going to
tell you that well he will tell you that
like friend Junior for sure but Scotty
give you access to things that like not
just me though like that's his hand so
the Scotty that were tough for me
hospital yeah Scotty but back in the
yeah now he has a hospital what's the
name of the hospital in Mexico chips
chips chipsa so he's doing a bunch of
great work uh helping people with stem
cells if you're interested in that you
can fly into San Diego go down across
the border this is way before this is
dude this is I mean when I'm one of
those guys yeah when I met those guys
they were living in like a like a
broken down Loft up in San Francisco me
and Dean list go up there for you know
to go out hang out training was the
coolest person at that point and maybe
one of the coolest people in America as
far as bringing people together
and show them a good time like because
not too many people were able to do that
how is he going to bring all these
people right whatever we think from all
shapes of life you're crushing it Pete
keep going
so what's when did you meet Scotty then
Jeffy I mean early he he was already
sponsoring Tyrone and Tyrone was like
you should look at my little white
brother
this guy he was like yeah he's awesome
and then as a blue belt I had an otm
patch on my ghee and
you know you so you started competing as
a white belt
you just started getting in there and
you were you were so you must have been
like 16 17 years old when you started
competing yeah I think the first one I
did was uh 17.
there's something about you though like
the whole time that you've been doing
Jiu Jitsu you've been doing things that
other people weren't doing
you've been doing things that at least
as far as I know it's kind of it's
similar to Dean Lister like my brother
Dean you know he was doing things that
literally people were not doing and
you're the same way
as a white belt I don't I don't know
that early on I was like that I think I
was doing
good I think I was doing Jiu Jitsu right
and just with really good motor skills
and
amazing balance and it was just normal
jiu jitsu but done in a way that looks
different you know yeah Dean was
actually doing different things Dean was
doing things that were like illegal
you know what I'm saying I was taking
the bathroom triangles doing bow and
arrow jokes you know I was I was doing a
text I guess you're right because now
that I think about a little bit more uh
you were doing normal stuff but damn
you're doing it in an abnormal way
because even today you can go watch your
videos from when you were a white belt
or a blue belt you're like that does not
look like normal Jiu Jitsu the fluidity
of your movement and you know you were
teaching class yesterday and you were
going through this thing where you're
like hey just sit here and bounce back
and forth and now and you're just
talking about Shadow wrestling and so
I'm sitting there like just doing what
I'm told like okay we're bouncing back
and forth and then you're saying like
hit a single hit a double and then
you're like all right stay in your
square but stay in your square but now
get get it down get down in half guard
get that deep apartment you're doing
this Shadow like there's no other people
and I'm watching you do it and I was
like damn I'm a loser I am such a loser
because I can see that you're getting
better
with no partner just doing the moves
doing the movements your brain is just
tapped into going through and making it
happen and I was like God I'm such a
loser
and you're literally saying like this is
how you can get better this is how you
get I'm thinking god I'm an idiot how
did I not be doing this for all these
years uh going back to the story though
you started competing you started
kicking ass really early I mean you were
freaking you came onto the scene in a
fury yeah yeah I mean for my against my
peers I always did really well hey how
many hours a day you're like oh Peter
more you must have been training
freaking I mean training like I think
when people say training they mean like
rolling oh I mean on the maps I mean I
was assisting in every class all of
frenzy is private classes his women's
self-defense classes his little kids
classes how long a day how many hours a
day were you at the Academy I mean it
was like if I missed more than two
classes the whole like free Jujitsu
thing was over
so you're you're doing five classes a
day four classes a day
yeah every day yeah but I didn't roll no
you're not gonna roll every single class
but that's the thing and I noticed
there's another thing about you
you have a way of rolling
that is
it's not rolling fully but it's rolling
it's like a playful role where you're
going through wild positions and crazy
things are happening and that's another
thing and you know it's I used to watch
you do this when you taught here and I'd
be like oh yeah that's awesome yeah and
I kind of thought of it as like a cool
thing and then I just realized when you
were here and I was watching actually I
was watching you and Pete roll and I was
like oh this is how this bastard's
getting so good because as he's trying
all this wild stuff against a partner
that he's kind of playing with that
playing together yeah and that's a
different thing and I remember that
actually Dean and I used to do that Dean
and I would do that where we're sort of
going
but we're also kind of just playing but
if it's gonna work you can kind of tell
it's gonna work and if it's not gonna
work you can tell it's not gonna work
but you don't get all locked up in one
position and sit there across the side
for 48 minutes which is not much you
have to play before you can fight it's
like in boxing a boxing coach won't hold
bats for you unless you're good at
Shadow Boxing and bag work first because
you're gonna [__] hit them you know
you're gonna hurt him as a jiu jitsu
coach I don't want to work with a jiu
jitsu student that doesn't have a good
stance I'm like let me see your stance
and they're like I don't know what to do
with my hands I'm like whoa you're not
I'm not rolling with that dude he's
gonna hurt me and if I roll with him I'm
gonna only only win there's no like
letting this dude get anything because
he's gonna do it wrong and hurt me you
know what I'm saying and then I start
feeling bad because I'm just breaking
some dude off like as hard as I can and
it's all brand new and he doesn't
understand I'm just trying not to get
hurt yeah well that was a another
interesting thing you told me one time
you said hey for me the easiest people
for me Jeff Glover to go against is like
big muscle guys
and I witnessed that countless times
where like some big Jack guy would come
in here and you could see you know
whatever he's thinking he's hanging on
to is not there anymore like a half a
second later it's gone you're all of a
sudden slipping over there slipping over
there
um how about your flexibility bro you
got some wild flexibility how much of
that is natural and how much of it is
work
I mean it's all natural I don't stretch
never stretched no God
that's crazy you ever see me stretch
Pete no
he just like does like freak Show
stretches just to show people like how
twist his ankles around but as far as
like going out there and doing a yoga we
went to like meet some chicks one time
how do I was it no I mean he was more
flexible on everyone like we're not
falling for that again no so you know
Glover is one of those people
you know what if you tell someone you
know not to use their strength but then
I tell them not to use their flexibility
so then
you know we all have talents that we
should but yeah the way Glover and I
play is uh
we warm each other up in case we really
have to do something
as far most people see we're expecting
to be rolling and then some dude wants
to challenge us so we're warming
ourselves up at all times
as opposed to hurting each other and
then someone walks in the room and then
what
yeah and we're already hurt like the way
we play he's getting sharper I'm getting
sharper and then if we really got to do
it
then we do it we're sharpening these
things pretty much we're not we're not
putting in battle because we already
know what it could do
but we'll keep it Sharp
this thing's pretty sharp no that one's
not sharp at all yeah so so Jeff you're
saying uh you know white belt blue belt
you're kind of doing normal Jiu Jitsu
moves you're just doing them super fluid
and again anybody go watch YouTube or
whatever and check out some of the stuff
well what's the first thing you remember
kinda kind of thinking hey I'm making
this up this is new like I I'm creating
this thing right now
I don't know that I did it intentionally
it would be somebody else pointing it
out to me and being like hey did you
notice you did this when you rolled and
I'd be like no I have no idea what just
happened
I was just you know responding to all
the training that fringio put me through
and it would just work you know you're
uh deep half guard is that I mean you're
definitely known for the Deep half guard
especially back in the day
do you was that something that you were
like all of a sudden you realized you
had this position I remember you
teaching me deep half guard
and the coolest thing was you do deep
half guard to me and you just like sort
of pose the question like what what are
you gonna do Jocko because you're 225
pounds and
where are you gonna go and you have you
have control of my leg
it's like your whole body is on my leg
but then I can't do anything
was a deep half guard is that was that
the first thing that you started getting
recognized for
as like your own thing it was our team's
thing frangia used it just as much as I
did so did Bill so did Tyrone
anybody who was winning tournaments from
Paragon team was using that [__]
Suite
um but I think I think what I did was
I recognized that all the sweeps
are not just randomly used it works best
when you have an initial off balancing
movement
and I realized at that point that I was
doing that I was going into deep half
guard and just trying random moves and
hoping they would work and often they
would they would oftentimes work I would
be like let me try this random move and
boom the guy would get swept like oh
cool
and then would you load that into your
repertoire yeah of like okay now I got
another sweet well I I dude it's I had
the light bulb when I realized it was
only three sweeps
I thought that it was like 15 20
different things I had to learn when I
found out that oh my God I keep
repeating these three things over and
over again and it took me so long
I used to do like three months so it
would focus on three months on one move
every time I rolled with somebody I was
only doing Alma Plata for three months
and at the end of three months I was I
was freaking I hated that move I felt
like a cheater if I was I was so good at
it that it wasn't fun anymore you know
what I'm saying when you got a move that
just works for you so well you feel like
you're cheating you know doing it to
white belts you're like what how good do
I really feel about that you know what
I'm saying I'm sitting the bar higher
for myself so it didn't get like that
with deep half guard it got to like year
three and four and I was still like
excited to use it every time I rolled
and it was making life so easy and you
started seeing the clarity and the
Simplicity actually getting narrowed
down over time because you thought that
your half guard with so many different
moves but really you can sweep them to
the left you can sweep them to the right
you can come out the back that's kind of
what it is basically yeah it's always
going to be a variation of one of three
moves yeah and they all set each other
up
they're all yeah there's a hole there's
a whole thing that's really easy to
learn you know if I can grab your leg I
can show it to you and explain it to you
in like five minutes and most guard
systems do not take five minutes to
explain most guard systems you need like
two hours
and I can honestly give you the gist of
this system in like under 10. no it's
Pete explains it better than I do to be
honest with you yeah it's one of those
things that when I when you when you
were teaching here and I was like this
stuff is it's crazy how it is pretty
simple I mean when you you were already
to the point when you came here I mean
you were a freaking champion and
everything else so you were not only
highly proficient at the move you're
also highly proficient at teaching it
and all the little drills another thing
that Jeff Glover has
drills little physical drills that make
you better at the movement that make you
better at jiu jitsu
motor skills somebody said that to me
the other day they're like Glover you
got motor skills yeah I was like
yeah what does that mean I said that to
you the other day when you were cute no
what I said was I feel like if Jeff
Glover's watching me try to do one of
his moves he just thinks this guy's an
idiot like this guy does but it doesn't
have any motor skills uh
so you're in this competition mode so
now we're talking like
what is it now Matt the year 2000 2001
now you're competing all the time 2002
2003 you're mopping up competitions the
other thing that's rad about Jeff Glover
is uh
what's Jeff Glover's weight class
whatever
dude all those old like grappling Quest
videos where you're going in against
guys that are 300 pounds literally 300
pounds 240 pounds jacked big giant dudes
what was the story behind that you just
didn't give a [__]
deep half Garden deep half guard the
bigger they get the more I use the Deep
half court yeah come out the back door
yeah no up on a single any of them they
all work really well
see if not when you're calling that
quarter guard position when someone's
trying to mount you
you if you look at the last 80cc with
the super fight at Gordon versus galvao
Gordon had him trapped in the quarter
guard so God had two options or three he
could either accept the mount turn the
stomach down give the choke or
he could have went and did Jeff Glover
right there and dive under the leg and
went deep half Garden that's something
you got to be kind of crazy to do it's
it's the Deep half the way I teach the
Deep half guard you'll never get mounted
again you don't get mounted and you
don't get your back taken it's the
anti-mount pretty much it's anti this
here's how Jiu Jitsu used to be when we
all first started okay it used to be you
go from closed guard to mount there's
none of this like knee slide to side
control [__] first it was go from closed
guard to mount and when dudes are good
at that it [__] sucks that's right
Roger Gracie does Gordon's so good at
that now he's so good at just going
straight to mount dude you know what I'm
saying and that's what I used to have to
defend with frangia all the time and
phrangia gave up on trying to tell
students to do that [__] because
everybody on the grappling scene they
were all like oh knee slide to side
mount Fringe he was like that's whack go
to mount and people like that but that's
harder and he's like yeah at first it's
harder but the end results dog you get a
mount where the submission is just right
there now it's like a Checkmate type
Mount and he was like whatever nobody
wants to listen to me and we are at the
whole Community we were knee slice knee
slides and now Gordon's showing you guys
[__] slice Mount right so pressure so
this deep half guard is is designed to
deal with that [__] to get under that
mount to deal with that [__] right there
that's how Glover is able to beat these
big guys because
he can either stay there and get trapped
and mounted or he can dive under and
Diving under is scary because they're
right above you and if you don't know
what you're doing right there most
people try it and then they they kind of
get a was it claustrophobic right yeah
they get claustrophobic and bail on the
panic and they're bail it Panic they're
like it doesn't work it doesn't work
yeah well that's another thing you and I
were talking about the other day Jeff is
when you first try a move in jiu jitsu
it's not going to work I mean it may
work like 10 of the time but it's the
same thing with anything in life when
you incorporate something new into your
life if you're working at a
at a business and you incorporate some
new process at first it's going to be
less efficient that's the way it works
so you're gonna no one knows exactly how
to do the process so everyone's kind of
messing it up and they're taking a
little longer and so you're gonna get
less efficient when you first start
trying a new process in a business same
thing in Jiu Jitsu you bring some new
move into jiu jitsu
it's going to make you worse for a while
and I said for a while you were like
three months
because you were teaching a whole nother
series the other day and
I was I said to you I'm like bro I'm
gonna get my back taken a lot when I
start doing this and you go yeah you are
and I was like yeah cool that's the way
it is and I got done I was rolling and I
was like hey I got my back taken and you
were like yeah you're gonna keep getting
your back taken for a while and I
remember there was a position I used to
teach and and I would teach it to people
for me it was like my main go-to
position of how to pass guard it was
like kind of Unstoppable and I would
teach it to people
and then I'd see them try and do it
they'd be all awkward and all off
balance and stuff and I would say to
them they'd be like I feel like I'm
gonna get swept and they would get swept
and I'd say hey man you got to get
comfortable in this position first like
it's going to take you a while to get to
where you can just be here and just be
like oh nothing's gonna happen you can't
triangle me you can't unlock me you
can't sweep me I'm totally comfortable
here and I'm gonna pass your guard but
it but it takes a while to get used to
that stuff in order to do that you got
to put your ego in check yeah
I remember watching you Jeff Roll you
like
people are just getting you're just
giving up a rear naked choke
eighty percent of time you get out 20 of
the time you tap and you're like cool
let's roll again
yeah well I was getting paid in those
classes you know
but that if you're not doing that
you're not going to improve
yeah I don't you know I like I like
making the students truly believe they
got coach
you know like like like they go home
they're like tonight
foreign
God I tapped coach today no he legit
like tapped hard and everything and he
was struggling and grunting
and I don't take time to explain to them
whatever they want to ask did I really
get you I'll be like oh you know I'll
explain it to them but if they don't ask
I let them go home I'm not going to be
like I let you by the way I let you get
that by the way just so you know
like I'm like done a good job today dude
you try to match their energy almost
yeah match match their heartbeat if they
start going harder we started going
harder
all right so when when did you
so what was like the highlight of your
competition career Pete well then well
okay so
let's see besides Rafael Lovato and and
myself there wasn't too many Americans
pretty much going
Raphael would come out and visit all the
time his dad was cool he wouldn't live
in Brazil but he'd come out and
so him and I were able to do well out
there
and so they put us in a great kid
pellegral we would usually get ripped
off in tournaments like we would I would
compete more than him but the Brazilians
liked us because we would get ripped off
there was no internet so much and
you know like the last time I competed
in Brazil's against brauliostimon is
like at my fifth match of the world and
I should have won but then they they
gave him a timeout they called the
referee he brought over a oxygen tank
right after a deep half guard swept them
I dumped him then they called a timeout
they brought him all the auction they
put him in his best move I didn't even
know what was going on
I was like
Carlson came out he made the switch to
rough he threw out uh one of one of his
cousins of the referee and then
and it was it was you just realized like
in these type of games you could get
cheated especially
in the tournament
basically we didn't
and those tournaments back in there you
just stuff someone in a position you
were good at and the time would run out
and you'd win that's how I wouldn't have
the flesh he wins because I would beat
people that I wasn't supposed to be I
would go to Brazil and beat all those
guys and they would never expect that
and I don't even remember most of their
names but there was a lot of good ones
and all the Brazilians knew me
and then when I came back to Chicago
Carlson had moved to Chicago
but the level was low because in Chicago
yeah it was just like regular people
training right and so I BJ pennant
called me he's one of friends at Scotty
and I went over there and I was I was
living with BJ Penn and that that was a
good highlight in Hawaii or Hawaii oh
okay so I lived over there for a while
so I'm like actually beat the Greek
Brazilian Sicilian Peruvian Hawaiian
there's a whole bunch of them so I lived
over there in Hawaii in Hilo
do you know Jack Daniel Jack Daniel Hill
he was another guy that lived over there
and and trained like six hours a day
yeah it was just me and DJ Penn all day
all day so he'd pick me up and
you know Hilo is one of those towns
where it's Adrenaline Rush all the time
it's raining and stuff and we're just
having fun cruising and have like Randy
Couture come in teach us how to wrestle
and
he fought Leota Machida at that time so
how long are you how long are you living
in Hawaii for for a while
can you put that in some kind of a time
perspective
I'm still there
they remember me
I was be honest with you I went back to
Brazil first time in 16 years it was in
the middle of covid everything was shut
down I'm talking about everything no one
on the street I brought gorilla hands
out there he's from Brazil but he never
been to Rio and he went with me
and they just let me and henzo out in
the street and we actually bumped into
each other just me henzo and gorilla
hands I have pictures and all of real
only people out in the street no kidding
and they thought I still lived there
they think I'm related to animals like
they think I'm one of them that's how it
is when I visit here but you look like
angels
I don't know we all look like each other
do you still live here you're moving
back they have no idea I ever left you
know wherever I go they still think I
live there if you go to Hilo you know
Pete even here I'm kind of still Jeff
and I are still here even though we're
not here yeah and so we leave that type
of presence because we love Jiu Jitsu
okay so for some unquantifiable amount
of times
in Hawaii Hawaii training with with BJ
Penn and this is when BJ Penn is like
fighting yeah just one he had just
beaten Matt he was licked the blood off
his face which also let me just throw
this out there too you were talking
about how sometimes the tournaments in
Brazil could be very tough for a
Un-American to win B.J Penn went down
there
video so if you get the video from that
year that match isn't even on the video
you know what I mean so it's like they
kind of like put that and he used to
train at Gracie Baja he's from health
Gracie but the same thing happened he
got there was a hundred black belts on
the mat the first day everyone trained
with him the second day no one wanted to
even touch him and so then he went over
to another team to Carlson Gracie
Blackwell novunyal
pettinares he goes over there as a
purple belt he tells me like Pete you
know like I walked up in there I was
nervous he walks up the stairs
and Hobson Moore is like one of the best
black bodies like I triangled him day
one and they're all like they were
surprised he was a purple ball
and then they were like talking [__]
they're like oh you know it was lucky he
goes back the next day he's like I
triangled him again
and then they gave him a brown belt and
they're a competition heavy team and so
they needed someone at black belt in the
weight class they put him and he won and
then I was there at purple belt the next
year
I think he won 2 000 so 2001 I was at
Purple belt they weren't gonna let that
happen again they're like no way dude
they're like
they're like you're not coming here and
doing that again so but you know people
like you if you're supposed to lose and
you win it's just like if you're a crowd
favorite people like you doesn't matter
what the medal says
and um I want a lot but then in Hawaii I
hurt my neck how do you hurt your neck
so we went to Sandy's Beach which is
like a notorious Beach for hurting
people and BJ Penn and them you see he'd
leave me in control a lot when he'd go
to Japan and stuff like he'd he would
tell his brothers Pete's in charge so it
left me like it was hilarious so you
know
after some time I ended up at this beach
and I hurt my neck so that took me out
of the competition scene that was right
what happened
I got body surfing I had no one called
Breakneck Beach Breakneck Beach I had no
idea that the most dangerous beach in
the world they didn't tell me they're
not going to tell you you know I mean
it's like you're in a you're in a room
full of Staff no one tells you immerse
or whatever it's like yeah you know just
lay on that couch
so it's the same that was a jab at me I
don't know if you guys knew that was an
outside jab at me because he thinks all
my couches have ringworm and stuff [__]
you man he didn't train on me but MMA
people when you if you go to their house
and you sleep on one of their couches
like it's like a joke they're like yeah
you can stay here as long as you want
just stay on that couch it's like a joke
because you know like day four wow
dude's just gonna be itching everywhere
wow I haven't had ringwormer stuff I've
been saying it Jeff doesn't do MMA it's
it's crazy MMA fighters from back in the
day I'm not talking Jeff is clean and
he's a he's a great friend he's a
conservative American well I I have
personally witnessed Jeff kicked people
off the mat for doing whatever kind of
stuff that that was uh non-hygienic
that's great but hey how so what what
was the injury to your neck so um I get
slammed on my neck
and I was like [__] dude I thought I was
paralyzed and I
and I man those little guys I heard some
people laugh and I started getting
pissed BJ Penn grabbed me out of the
ocean because they think it's funny like
if you if you get hurt at first kind of
[__] yeah ended up being hurt you know
end up being like into the entire series
of movies called jackass which is
literally about that right there and
like their main friend character he's
like you know anytime you want to come
back here we'll build a house for you
they're just like they're happy that
took it like a man because most people
are gonna be and I still stayed there
for months like four or five months did
you get surgery did you get it yeah it
was just it sucks so bad I ended up
taking numbness in your arms it was
[__] up at first when I got hit I was
completely numb I thought I was
paralyzed I was like I hit it and I was
like whoa and then you just shake
something off I was like whoa like whoa
I'm I'm paralyzed this sucks
I'm like this sucks and I kind of like
start accepting it and then I thought
about well one girl when I was in 18
years old I traveled to Cancun one of my
best friends she diagnosed in undertale
and they call me crying like we lost an
ocean I go out there I find her just
when I was 18. we're on the news and
everything in Chicago it came back
anyways first thing I thought of when I
thought of her when I got paralyzed I
thought her I was like whoa I was like
back in the ocean again like [__] I'm
paralyzed this sucks and I heard these
[__] laughing and then I felt the
pain come it was the best pain in my
life it was like real pain I was like ah
and I look at BJ pen I'm like I'm hurt
my friend and he's like he looks at me
grabs me up he felt like bad he felt so
[__] bad and he grabs me out and his
friends didn't know anybody I used to
smash them all day it was like purple
belts this random Hawaiians I'd smash
the [__] out of them they were so happy
random Hawaiians
I'm just saying like I was there for BJ
Penn I wasn't there like these guys are
just like adrenaline dudes like they'll
just show up like they're the type of
guys that show up when you win and they
run when you lose you know what I mean
he knows I'm talking about BJ Penn my
good friend so it's like those type of
friends they weren't like
top-notch friends so now you CA how long
before you [__] this [__] I go back to
Chicago
I'm pissed I was Pete the Greek
Brazilian Hawaiian back in Chicago I was
like [__] Carlson has lost his team he
was like [__] we became best friends
we're just like whoa we're like we need
to gather ourselves like he's on the
phone call like the shoot box coach
which is the other best team that hated
top team he's like telling them how to
dismantle everyone he's like yeah if
you're fighting like this guys like be
nice to minotaro because he wasn't a bad
guy but you just tell him how to
dismantle these people and they call
them up and it was just funny Carlson
was great and we would study MMA videos
every night and um not like like however
how Jeff and I started Jiu Jitsu we
study MMA and we watch Fedor and
everything Carlson what do you do here
and you stop it and explain it
and then I start learning and then we
met Stefan Bonner Stephen Bonner walks
in as a blue belt
and uh
like Carlson like focused put this guy
to fight you know big guy strong guy
tough guy we taught him to Kimura and
UFC calls up we're like hey put him in
because Carlson like that type of person
like people that I think are really big
Carlson has to talk to him like a kid
like Dana whitech you know put him in
and uh Stefan changed the whole damn
game well of course Vitor did before but
UFC got boring
until Ultimate Fighter came out and then
um that's why Dana White and all them
they love me
and no because we all when Dana White
come to Chicago he said Gibson's every
time he shows up he gets a wine from my
friend from Pete the Greek like
automatic like he's having like 50 times
so we go on there stuffing like blue
belt and those one move does like the
fight of whatever the century against
Forrest Griffin because when you fight
against Carlson guys that you have
Carlson staring at you so he's like he's
not a mean guy but he's a spiritual guy
so it's like you're just like [__] I'm
[__] are you fighting that guy you
find the whole history it's everything
stuff and he knew enough he did the
Golden Gloves boxing
knew the Kimura and he was strong if you
grab that damn Kimura your arms getting
ripped off
and uh he did that he changed the whole
game the UFC went from Rags to Riches
they were dying now everyone watching it
again UFC's huge people are buying
pay-per-views
and that's what I did when I was in
Chicago and Miguel Torres came too
we helped him out
and um at then he won the wec
and that's when Dominic Cruz took over
his weight class so it's all like
related and then I became from the
dominant cruises all like those are the
smaller guys a little smart guys when
did you open your Academy
so I had surgery Mark Coleman I'm over
at Cobra Kai
because for The Ultimate Fighter I was
like their bodyguard it was funny I'm
not a big guy but they like me so Steph
invites me and um so all the guys Chris
lieben they're all there
and I'm in the limo with them and it was
for The Ultimate Fighter Caesar won and
we were all it was like for the grand
finale so we're all at Layman's Cobra
Kai and what's his name tells me what's
that big restaurant Mark Coleman
I just had back surgery at Dr Joe it's a
guy in Pittsburgh and I show up there
and the guy fixing my neck
does like to dissectomy he's the best
he's like he's like a sniper he'll Fix
You So I go there
and I'm like yeah I'm here for Mark
Coleman he fixed my neck
but I didn't want to I didn't want to
to compete again I said shoot I'm like
one injury from being away from homeless
I better open a gym like it was like I'm
like looking for shelter like where do I
go who can I trust I'm back in Chicago
like I was living in Brazil
shoot Rio de Janeiro Hawaii and I'm back
in Chicago with a broken neck people are
laughing at me like I went and worked in
the ghetto of Chicago doing well um so
my friends they're getting all happy
like we knew you'd end up getting hurt
I'm like are you [__] [__] and
you got hurt you know what I mean it
doesn't matter that people see you like
you got hurt from that Jujutsu I'm like
okay
I'm like yeah I'm here to work a job
and so I got my real estate license and
I was working for my friends doing
Section 8 housing so I pick up people
from the projects the return on projects
and bring them to uh apartments and I
was like [__] dude like I don't want to
do this
and then
it was in bed but I'm a jiu jitsu guy
like I'm having to like really like I'm
like I don't want to really have to use
Jitsu I want to like I don't know what
I'm gonna do so I opened up this Little
Gym
like a real little one Glover came
visiting a sketchy neighborhood I
remember Glover's first day like the guy
comes in Glover's on the door waiting
for like you all do tap out because I
had a tap outside y'all do tap out wait
that's what Glover said you love her
outside the thing remember the first day
outside my gym he remember that because
I had a big Tapout sign so people in
Chicago thought that I did they thought
Jitsu is called Peppa right it's crazy
so then I am
I opened up this Little Gym everyone's
telling me you know you're gonna get
shot you're gonna I'm like yeah right
dude I open up the gym and Bam I get my
best friends best students right from
there so cool because right on North
Avenue and Western are two biggest
streets in Chicago so it pretty much
everyone can get there from the south
side and north side from downtown from
everywhere
it's a little gym like 600 square feet
and um man I mean my best friend from
there they knew I was hurt I told him
straight up I'm like look my neck is
hurt
I'm like you guys just got to get good
I'm gonna tell you what to do I'm not
going to fight you just learn how to
listen
and um man we got a lot of students in
there it was crazy like cars parked
outside next thing you know all my
friends are open up gyms next to me I'm
like oh thanks you guys are great
friends like you see business is going
great and
um
shoot Jim Jim got big kid students I
opened up a giant gym and um
things are going great Glover then came
to my giant gym I always have Glover up
for he's always about I'm like guys
we're having a seminar like what did you
guys meet for the first time
like with Scotty that was because that
was through Scotty everything's Scottish
I would have never been I would have
never been Scotty taught me how to be a
California boy I was just like Chicago
like cold winter I didn't know anything
I'm like yeah I just need to smash and
win fight and then Scotty shows you like
surfing he shows you everything
how to roll a joint stuff like that
Scotty had one of those scooters like uh
like a quick scooter in Brazil and we
would just go like he's going like 40
miles an hour on a scooter he had the
first digital camera Scotty's like from
the future
back then now I don't know I because now
he's with the hospital stuff I haven't
spent too much time with him but back
then he was from the future he'd teach
us all this stuff
and um man Hawaii Brazil everywhere I go
back to Chicago it's kind of like it's
like a community service like I'm I'm
really helping out people
um Chicago's like a barter system it's
like a third world country people don't
want to pay you that much they'd rather
just barter you and it works out good
because everyone there has like
connection to this and that and this guy
owns that place he owns a restaurant you
know if you try and charge him you end
up getting less so you're like hey
everyone trains for free
So my gym people pretty much pay um it's
like here you don't charge people that
much Jocko like no we try and keep it as
we try and keep it so people can come in
and I don't have people yeah I've
overhead much lower and so it's like
dude I know if you have money I know if
you know like pay what you think you
should like you know if there's food in
the kitchen eat what you deserve
and uh my guys understand that and I
could make a lot more money being there
but I wouldn't be in Jiu Jitsu like I'm
doing Jiu Jitsu service with the Glover
with the rotolos with BJ Penn all these
people I'm I'm doing a higher service I
could be at home teaching white belts
and they might quit in a few months they
might win a tournament and I can make a
lot more money for sure 100
but if I'm looking at it from service
like like we help the whole world we're
all over the place the weed is better in
California
and cheaper you know they're legal right
is it legal that's a big part of it yeah
Chicago you go to the store it's like 40
taxes you know
and um yeah I love Chicago hey I love
that place but with my broken neck see I
got hit by okay so I opened up the giant
gym bam Glover comes over like who are
we doing the summer with
Jeff Glover I'm like yeah again every
Summer's with Glover at my school like
it's it's just the way it is and so um
we had a couple other ones but most of
them like eight out of ten summers are
with Jeff
and uh the sickest I ever got
was one of the seminars I did at your
school you took me to the Burger King he
took me to Burger King twice on the same
day
yeah it was coming out of both ends and
I was you know
Pete's like you all right in there
Glover I was like I hate you man I'm
down in this basement you know like I
got a great home back in San Diego
waiting for me like this place was here
and I'm like in Pete's basement vomiting
I can just taste the like chicken
remember chicken fries oh damn I hate
that [__] this is gross oh it was bad
yeah that's whenever Pete talks about
this that's all I ever think about so so
my dad's feeling about the closest I
ever felt to death dude let me tell you
what happened on Sudden Jeff comes over
I'm feeling great and drunk drivers hit
me and and break my my neck again and my
back and then I was just like
I can't live here anymore it's too cold
and then I went and lived with Glover
Glover Glover would you say call him
you're my therapist did I I don't
remember that yeah you're my physical
therapist so then I met you guys so so
Jeff
when you started uh
compete when you started like competing
for real like now you're
like no when you started doing the
worlds
and it's like 2007 2008. what's your
life like at this point what's your
training schedule looking like it's just
Jiu Jitsu Jiu Jitsu Jitsu right I mean
the the Jiu Jitsu is the only thing that
was not chaotic
what what what's chaotic I mean just
like social life family life
finances where do you live where are you
living I mean like
I live Joe Stevenson let me live in his
place for like two months I mean I was
living all over I was living in all
these places and your whole uh existence
is just a train jiu jitsu
yeah pretty much are you are you still
with with frangia this whole time
I went between I started this is where I
started go realizing that like this one
place thing wasn't for me that just
being with fringia wasn't going to cut
it and Mark Layman was already
big influence to me making those videos
Mark Lehman was the first YouTube you
know and uh where's Mark Lehman he's in
Vegas he went back home to Michigan does
he have a school out there yeah yeah
he's all low-key though no Instagram
nothing he was a beast but he was very
influential and uh it's cool because I
get to say now I trained with Mark and
Dean yeah because Mark and Dean were the
two it was like who were the best
Americans at the time it was always Mark
Lehman and Dean Lister yeah and they
fought and I got to be you know I've
spent so much time with both those guys
and um yeah you know I started doing the
mark thing and I told Franzia Mark
offered me a job in Las Vegas a
full-time teaching job it was my first
full-time teaching job and friend Gia's
school it was like Franzia can you match
what Mark's offering me and he was like
sorry boy I can't you know if you want
to keep assisting me for free that's
cool I was like well
so I went to Mark Lehman and like when
Fran gave him my black belt
he tied it around my waist and I had
already told him you know I was making
the move and he like in my ear he was
like you know he was like boy go show
those guys how we do the Paragon Jiu
Jitsu into Las Vegas I'm proud of you
you know what I'm saying he's like you
you welcome back anytime boy yeah you
know what I'm saying so so I started
going between those two places
and actually that's like when I started
hanging out with like Rudy that's when I
met Rudy at tournaments and Rudy would I
would come visit Rudy and that's how I
started making friends with all you guys
right off you know and um
it was like yeah that's how many hours a
day are you training at this time period
I mean
in every class I would teach and I would
take Mark's classes yeah so it was still
it was still until recently it was like
you know four times a day every day um
eight to ten hours and I met
we take naps so how many hours a day are
the rotolos on the mat right now like we
gotta take naps once in a while frequent
cat naps yeah and then like you got to
be in nature I think nowadays a
different training now we do more nature
training because just do recovery I'm
all about recovery now yeah it's good to
be outside a lot
[Music]
i surf with them they like they surf a
lot
uh
when you were training and like let's
say you were getting ready for 80cc or
you're getting ready for you know the
worlds
how much drilling you doing
nothing changed I was I I did everything
the same I I think there was one
tournament that I actually had like a
professional coach
but it was just like a jiu jitsu coach
no like a Fitness Nutrition a guy named
Chris Eklund in 2011.
and uh he had me doing all kinds of [__]
how did you feel I mean I I that was the
best year in my competitive life yeah
so he he you stepped it up
and then that made you better he would
he would like
frown at me if I was baked
you know he'd be like yeah
you're making me feel bad for all the
times that I've smiled at you and you
were baked yeah like you know he would
be like what did you eat today and like
stuff like that and make sure I did like
real like weight lifting stuff and that
that was 2011 and I had the best results
that year
hands down
did but other than that I never trained
hard I know I mean I trained hard but I
didn't work out right there was no
weight there was no s what do you call
it stadiums there was no stairs yeah
there's no elastic bands there was no
box jumps yeah there was Taco Bell it
was Taco Bell video games and just dope
ass Jiu Jitsu yeah that's interesting
the best technique the most like dork
about it I would go down the rabbit hole
of what's next what's next move after
that 20 30 move combinations before the
dude would just give up and I would tap
them Glover trains in his sleep I think
that's where that's where the magic
happens Dean does that too like you know
when he would fight and we'd all like we
were all broke and everything and so
we'd all stay in like one hotel room and
like I'd sleep on the floor but you'd
like wake up and Dean would be there
like asleep but he would be trying he'd
be like like not just his legs would be
in a triangle and like triangling air
and then you'd see him like roll over
but he roll over he would like he would
like adjust his feet and get like a body
lock
I'm not kidding like that's where he
would sleep like he would sleep he'd be
doing Jiu Jitsu when he was sleeping or
like he'd be asleep and his his hands
would be like on her rear naked like
he'd be asleep like one hand under his
head but his hands are in a rear naked
choke so he's just like dreaming of of
Jiu Jitsu and sleeping sleeping that way
I met Dean in Brazil when I was out
there uh he'd hang out my dad and I my
dad came and my dad's a big strong guy
too like Dean like I'm a runt compared
to my dad and uh he just loved me
hanging out with Dean he's like
your friend is a cool guy strong guy
Pete you know he's like looking at me
like Why can't I be like Dean you know
I'm just like whoa so like they'd always
hang out it was like for like three
weeks and Dean showed up to Scotty's
house
and that's where I met him because
Scotty a little man I lived at Scotty's
house on the weekend during the week I
lived uh mostly Oswaldo owls which is a
little gym where Andre gawal lived in
and jackery we all lived in there
together Andre was a blue belt
and at that time it would that place
they would lock the door on Fridays so
if if they locked us in we'd have to
stay inside there was no way out it
would be like the door to Victory locks
on on Friday until Monday so me and
Gloria figure [__] out on the weekend if
we're living in the little it was a
little gym a little bit bigger in here
so
I would leave and go to Scotty's house
in Baja it's like 40 minutes away I was
like vacation Scotty had his house set
up like a hostel so all these people
would come stay they have the mats I
think we had the original he had Dean
brought the guys from um I think they're
their original friends of yours
and he brought them and Dean wasn't
allowed to train they wouldn't let him
train anywhere because he went like the
year before and leg locked everyone so
he was banned from every gym and he had
80cc coming up and I was kind of in a
similar situation so we just um Scotty
had a little thing right in the in the
in the living room and Dean just trained
with me
and he went the first day and lost it
was Tony de Souza was also staying over
there Tony he got disqualified for
making the guy too bloody they
disqualified him for being too mean to
the opponent no one even seen that match
but Dean Dean is kind of bummed out he
went and hung out and like we hung out
with some chicks and had fun that night
and he's like I'm gonna do the absolutes
and no expectation the winning goes
there and just crushes it yeah and then
tells like whoa dude like this is so
cool like
that's an yeah that's what I meant Dean
he just became 80cc champ it was like he
just turned in like National Superstar
Brazil like after that fight and he
leglocked everyone and then like I kind
of felt happy about that and I was
reading I couldn't go down I was I was
uh I couldn't go down for whatever
reason to because normally I would
Corner him right yeah and I couldn't go
down and so I'm reading
the updates
on the interwebs in the guard forums no
it was not in the guard it was on the
submission grappling I think
submissiongrappling.com
and they're putting but they're it's a
translation
from Portuguese but it's like some kind
of a computer translation that someone's
translating it and posting it and I
remember paid upono that in in
Portuguese that translates to cloth foot
and so it's saying like the American no
cloth foot has the American in an arm
strangle and it says this American has
tubes to his lung the cloth foot cannot
make him tap it was and I'm like oh dude
he's waiting and then it's like uh the
American got his back and I was like ah
you know I'm like reading this after I
was in my car I was in my freaking
minivan yeah I was like in my minivan
like ah yeah you know totally fired up
that he's he's doing this and ends up
with the dean's like a national hero
anywhere I go like if we go to Brazil
he's like we hung out in Chicago it was
great I just feel like Dean's in there
in the bars
yeah I'm his friend he's a great person
shoot he you guys really helped out
Glover and I because my dad like I said
he's like a strong Alpha dude but I
didn't really grow up with him that much
I worked with him
and I think Glover in the same we have
strong moms and stuff but like meeting
you and and seeing how you do things
really helps us like uh right Glover we
got we got pretty serious mostly echo's
arms kind of so we got seriously like we
definitely tried to better our lives
from meeting you like that's the truth
lover right I'm joking of course you
know that you guys know that yeah Jeff
when you when you
you always give Dean some some credit or
a lot of credit actually when I watch
Like interviews you'd be talking about
Dean and you'll be talking about like
how he helped out your leg lock game
what did that happen when you were
teaching here you were already
leglocking and he looking people right
yeah but I mean dean motivated all of us
yeah anybody even those who didn't train
with him we were all like what is this
guy doing leglocks are [__] yeah but
Dean
you know best comeback ever yeah but you
know what I'm saying and frangia that
was the one when that was when friend GF
was like I've heard him admit like
leglock's worked he was like look
there's this guy Jeffy I was like what
there's this american guy he's tap solo
leglock Jeffy
you know he was like
on a sad day dog [__] yeah but uh you
know it's like the dean made it okay for
us you know that when an OG would be
like no no no be like shut up you grumpy
old OG this guy's making them they're
legit so it is true you know
yeah that's uh what about the game like
I'll read about your game like you'll do
donkey guard which is for anyone that
doesn't do Jiu Jitsu it's gonna be kind
of hard to explain but just imagine
someone that you're gonna fight
and what they do is they turn around get
on there get on their hands and knees
and like jump go attack you with their
ass basically is what it looks like if
someone doesn't know yeah that's
freaking Mayhem dude yeah well it's it's
it's you know it's based off defense
it's based off self-defense I'm a master
of people grabbing me so you wrap them
together you know what I'm saying I
encourage you to grab me in positions
that
you know they think is good and and my
self-defense [__] kicks in and it just
does what it does and I have a heel hook
you know it's a combination of like the
flying leg scissors technique you know
um that and just kind of doing things
backwards the level of confidence that
you have
it might be unmatched I don't know if
anyone wants to Echo I would agree
unmatched level of confidence level
unmatched like no one's even close I
think it's an unmatched level of
confidence to see you compete and see
you
just offer positions to your opponent
that seem insane
and you would rather look stupid than
look scared
[Music]
well I don't think I also don't think
that there's been a Grappler
that is more
I hate to say this word but like more
entertaining to watch like watch it like
I could watch you
I could watch you all day Roll Jiu Jitsu
I could watch you all day like I told
you I have like videos of you and my son
like like you know one one year one like
the next year like eight minute videos
you guys are just rolling and I just
I'll just watch them because it's just
even though you're going against a kid
oh my God what is he doing here oh look
at what he's doing right there but then
when you watch you compete the same
thing it's freaking um amazing to watch
yeah thank you yeah I've worked very
hard to be as good at Jiu Jitsu as I am
that level of confidence though I'm kind
of unmatched
I mean even like you've been teaching a
series this week it's like stuff I've
never even well it's weird because
you started teaching this series
and you know I watched you here for five
years I watched you give your back to
people I watch you like do these weird
positions I'm like wow man that's just
like a Jeff Glover thing and then you
were explaining it the other day I was
like oh this is not just a Jeff Glover
thing it's just that Jeff Glover's doing
something that I didn't understand yeah
yeah which is I I trust my jiu jitsu
don't you trust your Jiu Jitsu sometimes
not as much as you do bro at all I trust
in it dude my coach used to tell me
believe and I believe dude yeah I
believe Jeff doesn't reference other
people and he does things he'll just
think of it and do it way cooler no
that's like that's why I say dude I feel
like an idiot like you're like oh don't
you trust your Jiu Jitsu I'm like well
not as much as you do bro apparently
because you're just in there just not
caring what happens and still you know
Jeff moves well I'm the worst actually I
think I'm the worst people ask me about
you everywhere go do my seminars they're
like what's it like to roll a Jocko
and I always tell them like you were
always so nice to me you and Dean and
Echo you guys are always you know so
gentle with me I'm so little and I go
all hard and you guys are like cry
little Jeff and like one one time you
actually like turned it on and put me in
a Kimura you know and people love when I
tell them that like there's no point to
that besides people being like whoa
he's really good no that's that's well I
was you know would feel like I wanted to
learn how to kind of roll that that way
where you learn more you know I'm not a
guy's real nice to me I'm not a good
roller and learner uh you're that's what
you do and I tried to like get that from
you to be a good roller and learner yeah
which is it's ridiculous yeah yeah it's
it's more fun that way you know no I can
see that's something that lasts longer
to this day for sure yeah I mean I got
like neck surgery right I get neck
surgery freaking Dean this you're trying
to choke me and I'm not tapping yeah
Dean wasn't as nice to me as you guys
were
yeah Dean would hold me like growl in my
ear and [__] look at Glover he can't get
up look at by the way everybody
everybody come here look at it
by the way you ever seen uh you ever
seen a man get out of this watch Clover
try to get out
look he can look how weak he is oh check
it out that's that's like being nice
compared to what Dean is up to you I've
seen you've been dude
it's humili it's it's like a a test in
humiliation right yeah like I gained a
lot of respect for you how can I do Jiu
Jitsu I have 225 pounds I lift weights
every day
freaking training Jiu Jitsu every day
and a a me I'm a grown man
and Dean would put me in positions
where I could not move or he you know
could not look could not move my body in
any way how's that happening I remember
you'd say that and he's like holding me
with one and he doesn't lift weights no
you're like d never lifts away and he
would say stuff like that he'd be like
he'd be like you need more CrossFit
I thought you could squat a lot what are
you doing how's that squat working out
right now oh that's perfect that's so
good yeah we all say that yeah he did
that it's good but it's not good but but
so so speaking of like the dean Mr Jocko
thing because I will say thankfully
I've got to be Dean lister's guy you
know in those years when he was becoming
a champion I was the guy I would train
with him every day we trained two hours
three hours four hours a day you need to
have someone like that in your life uh
you had Bill the grill yeah right that's
your guy so anybody that's doing Jiu
Jitsu you need to find that that guy and
the only Pro like we talk about the play
for rolling and look I just talked about
Dean
like humility and believe me he'd
humiliate me any day I'd get a position
on him bro I would go twice as hard
humiliating him and having fun with it
payback's a [__] though but for jiu
jitsu you gotta find somebody or like
it's probably gonna be one person it's
hard to even find more than one person
like this but someone that's gonna be
your
like true brother teammate That You're
Gonna Roll with You're Gonna Learn with
you're gonna work on stuff you're gonna
stay after you're gonna drill stuff
you're gonna get Tapped Out by each
other you don't care it's just like that
you had build a grill yeah how'd he come
into the scene he just he did you know
he just started showing up how far
behind he he's he's five years younger
he was 13. he was 13 when he started but
we had him in the adult class by the
time he was 15 he was the purple belt
national champion
breaking off adults him and chrome
Gracie made it to the finals of a
tournament they were both 15 years old
tapped eight dudes on the in the way to
meet each other in the finals
and it was like you know like dude kids
can be really oh dude I had that
conversation with Lovato Junior we were
at ADCC because he was like 17. he was
he well actually you're gonna know he
was 17. I don't know how old I was but I
was like 20. I was maybe even I was a
girl definitely a grown man
and I was like dude you beat me because
I said dude you beat me I said we were
purple belts you beat me and he goes I
beat you twice
you'd be in the weight class and he beat
me in the absolute bro and I was like
hell yeah that's a 17 year old I I don't
remember how he beat me in open but he
swept me like I you know sometimes you
get swept and you're just like man I
hope no one got that on video because
you feel real ignorant you like landed
on it yeah he just did like one of those
sweeps to me that I was all just dumb
and uh you know it was just awesome but
yeah a guy that's young you know I don't
care like a 17 year old can work out a
lot but he's not gonna be he's not gonna
have man strength yet you know and that
was badass Lovato just just just retired
but man it made it two rounds
at ADCC against the best in the world
it's hard for me to talk about Levato
because he's a good dude he's just he
just came to my gym
it's just so much to say we met him from
Scotty too yeah yeah good friends
there's another one otm I would see him
at every tournament and yeah we were
Bros yeah
those got well him you you guys were
just competitors he would go to he would
go train with Layman a lot a lot of
people would make their way to Vegas to
spend time with Layman and I would run
into them there because Layman hired me
as his Jiu Jitsu teacher for two and a
half years
how many classes a day were you teaching
there like you know a full-time thing
like like I was doing here like four a
day
I almost had that job too it was a good
job a Layman job Layman job but I went
to I went to Hilo instead because what I
used to do is this I used to stay in
Vegas
Monday through Thursday and then drive
over to
to Los Angeles is after I got back from
Brazil I would drive over to Los Angeles
and train at Eddie Bravo school and
that's how I met them Joe Rogan Eddie
Bravo uh Tate Fletcher oh yeah that was
in the bomb squad I had my friend uh Rob
Cayman uh he's the Dutch kickboxer and
they're over there and so because in in
Vegas the hotel's like 40 bucks a night
at Stan Harrah's and the weekend like
300 I'm like oh I'm going to L.A I would
say it's Scotty's brother's house
sometimes Cade which was um I also used
to live there so when Scotty left Brazil
he became like the Los Angeles guy so
anytime we go to La we hit up Scotty and
Scotty knew everyone and everything and
and shooting Glover that's when I got
hurt you know I was I wanted to be an
MMA fighter so I I was more interested
in like I'm like you know I'll put the
metals aside what was your weight BJ
Penn I was a lightweight light in the
middle when did you guys
see the nogi versus the ghee like at
what point did you see that as sort of
what you were gonna do 80cc that would
be like one
well if my Coach Carlson he didn't like
the ghee like um Elio Gracie put him to
fight his first MMA fight with the ghee
and he told I'll never do that again
you're crazy
took that down
and um and that was that and then that
Carlson crazy team never really used the
ghee to they used it for the kids
they use it to warm up but the best guy
is like Carlson would just grab some by
the neck like this it doesn't matter if
they're a kid or not and if they'd
Flinch like he's like no no you're just
Jiu Jitsu and if you go like this and
the kid in a car he's like okay you're
fighting even if they're adult it's just
he's not gonna he was already older but
he was like this like and the kid's like
like a man you grab Nick Diaz like that
he's gonna be happy yeah like oh you're
about to fight you're gonna hear it and
so that's that's hard team was um and
Carlson he was nicer to the bigger guys
like so I feel like arona's size can be
real nice to you I feel like my size
it's kind of like but you know what Pete
like Jeff gets the same way doing Jeff
gets around the big big guys he he gets
mean to me a little bit Carl's in the
same way
no but I'm just saying like big people
they give a good presentation as far
like Dean he's an example you I respect
bigger I respect size I'm a little dude
big dudes scare me
he likes whether they know Jiu Jitsu or
not whoever always has big friends do
some strong tough guys do like come
around like [__] the weird thing about
Dean's he's a mutant because he's still
so flexible
he is crazy it's a weird flexing
especially he's like taller Brothers
like Glover like BJ pennies they're all
special like
what do you think they're special people
right we're all pretty special Jackal
like Jiu Jitsu people are some of the
coolest people in the world today are we
have the DNA like it's it has to be in
your DNA to be a superhero at least
knows something
Jitsu yeah well there's there's
definitely a threat of like uh it's you
know they say uh martial arts right like
it's an art like it's an art form and
then you think it's stereotypical artist
you think like somebody a rock and roll
artist like he's a little bit crazy like
a painter is a little bit crazy a poet's
a little bit crazy let's face it the
Jujitsu player is gonna be good he's
gonna be a little bit gonna have a
little bit there's a decent chance I
should say he's a little bit crazy
especially like a deep half guard or to
go under someone like that yeah you have
to be but you got to be you know when
you talk to Dean
you you start talking to him about Jiu
Jitsu he knows weird things about Jiu
Jitsu it's like you were saying about
Glover the other day like you asked
Glover some questions some detailed
question about some weird section of Jiu
Jitsu and all of a sudden he's talking
about something and you're like how do
you know that how's it possible that's
the way that's the way Dean is have you
ever asked Dean like
if you say Dean like what uh Hey Dean
I'm having trouble with this triangle
and he'll say what kind of triangle and
you say what do you mean and he'll say
well there's nine types of triangles and
you know then he'll tell you what they
all are and tell you all the specifics
about it he made his book like that he's
I think like uh
let me tell you a story about Dean we're
we're at a uh an event
and we were doing some Jiu Jitsu like
presenting basic Jiu Jitsu kind of
self-defense to a few hundred people
yeah and uh he's showing a way to escape
someone's like bear hug right this is
basic Jiu Jitsu or basic self-defense so
you grab a bear hug and he's showing oh
you put the one hand in front of the
face and you put the other hand
underneath that one and you can make
space and you push the person away and
so he shows it a couple times this hand
goes here this hand goes here you push
him away make space boom and he goes any
questions
and a guy in the audience says uh hey I
have a question Dean says yeah what's
the question the guy says I only have
one hand and he holds up like he's only
got one hand
uh what what should I do and Dean
without missing a beat like just
instantaneously goes oh if you only have
one hand you put this hand here you use
your shoulder he like had the ultimate
solution
for a person that only has one hand
that's doing Jiu Jitsu self-defense
like that's
some Next Level knowledge you know what
I'm saying he can improvise because of
the amount of knowledge he has when he
improvises it's not [__] yeah that's
the weird thing it didn't even he
answered it so quickly he didn't even
need to you know I would need to be like
well come on out here let's look at it
let me look let's go through it Dean
like knew what to say no he's good he
doesn't know how to not say anything
else
it's freaking crazy uh Jeff what
injuries have you gotten from jiu jitsu
all of them you know what's the worst
one I mean I had a back surgery
but I can't even say that that happened
from Jiu Jitsu the injury itself uh I
don't know where that happened I don't
know how that happened
but I had like would you have just micro
desk with me is what I had you know and
so they pulled some discs out where in
your back lower back yeah my lower back
and uh that that was the most miserable
long chronic pain I've ever had it
wasn't like the pain that people get
down their legs yeah
I was crawling it was to the point where
I was I would wake up
cry for like an hour you know crawl into
the shower and then crawl back to bed
call some one of my friends to come feed
me I mean it was just horrible you know
that must be you texted me one time I
can't remember it dude I was like taco
help me somebody help me do my back
hurts
I mean I know shit's getting serious
like somebody help me it was bad dude I
was eating Advils and [__] because I
don't want to take like I don't know I
don't want to take like pills yeah I was
like I'll take the Tylenols or whatever
how long ago did you get that back
surgery that was in April and so how's
the recovery it's good I'm back to me I
mean Jocko I wasn't even teaching
classes I couldn't you know I couldn't
do anything like I'm I'm back to
bye like I didn't want to be able to
roll again and I'm rolling again I was
like I was like listen doc I'm not
trying to get you to fix me to the point
where I win World titles dog I just want
to be able to like be on the mat and
show a move to somebody without crying
you know and and now I'm at the point
where I'm like [__] dude should I take
matches
like nothing hurts anymore man my
surgeon is a jujitsu guy oh he's one of
friends he is uh students and um and
what do you do a disc out of me Micro
desk out of me so he pulls some little
disc out get it away from your nerves
yeah rupture disc yeah something like
that Jeff took pictures of it yeah no
they recorded it they took a whole they
were they showed like just break it up
it looks like little teeth the doctor
was just so kind to me man he he you
know he's like you know see you tomorrow
at 6am for surgery yeah he's like what
it doesn't take a week or nothing he's
like nope tomorrow see you there got it
I just got it done boom and how long did
it did the relief was like instant
really as soon as I woke up from
anesthesia
I was like so happy were you scared
about getting back surgery not at all or
you were just like hey I've had enough
that was done because I know a lot of
people you know they go through that
time period where like I don't want to
get surgery which I get yeah because oh
yeah well I did that I went through that
like I'm in a foundational training it
away yeah there's like a stance that I'm
gonna hold for three minutes and it's
like none of that [__] was working yep
so you guys tried all that stuff and
it's not working out and eventually the
pain gets to a point I know people that
have had surgeries and they haven't gone
great and it sucks so I generally tell
people like hey if you can put it off
put it off and then at a certain point
you gotta go okay look I tried and this
isn't working and I know a lot of people
that have gone just like you they they
went and got surgery and they wake up
and they're like oh I'm Healed I mean
imagine that go from debilitating pain
which is what you had you wake up and
you're healed I did that what surgery
was that well I had five
so the first one it's just the first one
in Hawaii they cleaned it out that was
fixed and then later on like I had
the Glover one in my lower back but it
went bad sometimes with those things
like when you get it cut the disc that
just comes back like your Peach scar
your scar is so big like my scar that I
have from the thing you can't even see
it dude when I had my car accident with
the drunk drivers
they I also it made my neck numb again
my arm and my legs so I had both I was
like whoa
yes no these ones there's only here too
I don't know there's somewhere I don't
know
but I have artificial discs in there and
so when they put that in there
it took away that numbness I was just
like oh
but it still gets sore of course it's
not perfect but it took away that you're
just like and I thought I was getting a
discectomy in there whatever they call
it I went into surgery thinking they
were going to clean it out and I'm
reading on a thing that says disc
Replacements too I'm like oh [__] I'm
like disc Replacements are only like 10
years old 12 years old in the neck yeah
and so it's awesome right yeah so he
says well I did it in
I met these people I was okay I can't
tell you everywhere but I've Been
Everywhere
but I'm also friends with Higgin Machado
and I was helping him he was helping me
I guess we help each other we're friends
in Beverly Hills at his school I was
teaching Ashton Kutcher and all the John
Wick guys and they had recommended
Daniel Bernhardt so he's a director he's
the guy that took over it's either
Michael or Daniel he took over after Van
Damme remember like in kickbox she was
like Van Damme then it became like some
other guy that became him and then he is
the director of all the Matrix stuff and
so his kids like me a lot I was teaching
them private lessons
um and who else is all they got Joey
Diaz I gave I got Joey Diaz in the Jiu
Jitsu actually he
um
he did a comedy show in Chicago and he
calls me it was in Indiana he calls me
up he's like uh Pete the Greek I haven't
met you but they tell me you're the guy
if I'm in Chicago so I went out there to
his comedy show on after show um I'm
like he was talking about martial arts
with passion I'm like dude you need to
join jiu jitsu and he's like serious I'm
like and he got like a tear in his eyes
and he went back when he went back home
he actually joined and when I show up to
Higgins
I saw him there and I did a video on
everything and
he can just a cool dude I don't know why
I even brought him up but I just think
of him he's like a Dean he's one of
those big dudes that like that people
just feel inspired around and um she got
the shoot if those guys met Glover they
would have went nuts madly like me
they're freaking no Keegan used to make
a point to come to me at every
tournament and say the nicest stuff to
me dog no kidding he's like his boy is
genius he's genius you said like stuff
like that but I talk you were so cool
and nice to me thank you and we used to
hang out Dean and hegan and I am in
Brazil my dad and stuff it was like our
little crew and uh that's what Higgin
did he went to everybody like everybody
that was coming up and was cool he would
go up to them and just encourage the
[__] out of him that's pretty cool you
know there's like a zero player hater
in that dude's body and yeah like I have
a rule with him like we're not allowed
to talk about Jiu Jitsu he's like he's
like he likes me because I remember him
of Carlson Gracie Carlson was his
favorite uncle he's like if the Machado
Brothers could have trained with anyone
they wish they would have trained with
Carlson because that was this part that
they didn't get into the Mixed Martial
Arts part because they didn't have him
as the coach like if Carlson was our
coach we would have fought and so I
remind Egan of Carlson a lot he loves to
have me around and and I met all those
those high-level people and and Joey
Diaz and I just want to say man things
because that was part of my rehab too
was um I lived at Higgins house for a
while before he rehab for your neck
um yeah just like um or if you get back
let me think which one it was car
accident the car accident got both of
them because you got I was on the news
in Chicago it was a big thing like
took me in all that stuff and it's
the gang bangers tried to run off so
they hit me and they ran off and it was
funny I'm like these [__] are running
and they're running away they're running
out of the minivan they hit me and then
you start dropping because they were
injured too and then like they take me
to the hospital and they thought I was
part of them they're like no just listen
here buddy I'm like look I'm the guy
that got hit like we don't want to hear
that I'm like get me out of here and I
just left and that was like um the same
hospital and you see the Joker and
Batman like he's blowing it up it's
called Saint Elizabeth it's right over
there in Chicago I live right in the
Chicago's cool I mean I come from a
pizza family a hot dog family I'm
Sicilian and Greek so my grandma's side
is uh the rotolos it's funny they're
they're Italian they're dead
he's actually I think we're cousins we
figured it out last night
because their their restaurant their
relationship is called La Villa that's
the last restaurant with my mom before
she passed away it's right by our house
it's one of the old old school
restaurants
um
shoot it looks like this guy was from
Chicago it's shy town it's a little town
we all know each other and um
shoot Glover over here I'll tell you one
thing I've met a lot of creative people
Scotty was creative like Glover in his
own way as far as putting everyone
together so Scott I know I keep bringing
up Scotty but man I wouldn't have met
any of these people without him he like
propelled Jiu Jitsu through
uh provided a lot of fuel for jiu jitsu
when there wasn't much fuel for jiu
jitsu in Brazil he thought he was
Pakistan he thought I was Carlson
Glover's like holds Gracie like maybe
like different Spirits fine I don't know
thinking like that maybe we find them
but holes in Carlson were business
partners uh holes was the best black
belt from the other side of the family
and when he became
black belt he would come to Carlson's
and train and sometimes these guys would
beat him there's like two guys that
could beat holes at Carlson and whole
says you know I want to train with you
guys
and so holes came over and Carl said
wait a minute you're not going to teach
at my class you can have your own class
so at Carlson's school they had two
rooms so Carlson would teach in like
room a Monday Wednesday Friday and then
holes would take that room Tuesday
Thursday Saturday and they'd Switch and
Go to the other room the other days
and then they would have a friendly
competition between their students and
that's how they kept the level so high
so when the holes got the holes was
black belt he his his best black belts
were Carl carlinos Gracie you know he
had he had Fabio Santos yet and Carlos
Gracie Jr but most of the guys went to
carlinos when holes died because they
want to stick with the Gracie family but
the best one of those guys not the
competitor the most technical was jokery
kawakanti that would be like where
frangina comes from so that was the most
technical of holes the old the old the
the white one yeah so he
I'm more like Carlson's side like you
know no it's not gonna work [__] and
Glover's like no no no just grab me here
grab me there so that's why we're
probably friends because we kind of
we're kind of like opposites
Jeff what was the discussion you had
with uh Henry Gracie the other day uh
sport Jiu Jitsu self-defense what was
that what was that discussion about
um
yeah it was like a meme that I saw and
it was like stuffed it was talking about
how how people in in like self-defense
Jiu Jitsu will say something like oh you
know they have problems with tournaments
sport Jiu Jitsu I don't do that sport
Jiu Jitsu [__] well I do that uh
self-defense style and he was like
imagine a boxer telling you that it'd be
like I don't do that sport boxing [__] I
just do that self-defense boxing it's
like how crazy would they sound saying
that right so this is this someone that
might think well oh yeah oh you do that
you know you train on a map with a Geon
that's not realistic so you'd get your
ass kicked in a real fight I mean listen
whatever it was it was a funny ass meme
then I posted it and then and then one
of his one of his students some dude
wrote just some some pretty hostile like
you don't know what you're talking about
[__] Glover so I went to his page and I
saw that he was like this scrawny
35 year old dude like my size you know
and I'm like and [__] this dude you know
so I I like I like to go back I took a
screenshot of his belt that he had
because he had a belt that I had never
seen and I'm like what is this some
karate belt you know and I was like look
at this is the kind of guy who like
argues with me about anything in Jiu
Jitsu is some dude who doesn't even do
Jiu Jitsu and Hannah was like hey what
up Jeff send me a message
and I found out that Hannah has his own
belting system I didn't know that dog I
didn't know I was personally he was like
oh that was a personal attack bro
and I was like Hey first of all as your
friend because I've known him for a long
time since we were both like you know
17. I was like as your friend if you
feel like I personally attacked you
honestly whatever it was I apologize I
was like I don't want to personally
attack you you're the man dude but like
on a professional level I didn't know
yeah you had your own belting system and
that I was like making fun of one of
your dudes well you know you know what
I'm saying and he's like yeah dog we
have this whole system and he explained
it to me for like an hour
and that you know I have 80d dude I
can't be listening I can't imagine you
having a one hour dude I'm pretty
surprised we're holding out right now
well that's that's how I ended the
conversation it was like the weed is
wearing off
uh you made your point you know what I'm
saying I'm sorry I hurt your feelings
um yeah we all do basic Jiu Jitsu but I
don't think like
I don't think like people who only do
self-defense will ever be able to beat
somebody who does Sport Jujitsu and
that's the end of my point I had a guy
on social media over the last couple
days
um he he posted something I wish I could
get the exact quote for you but it was
something like this and I get this
Spirit of what he was saying he said you
know I know this guy he was something
along the lines like this guy wants me
to train jiu jitsu
but I told him listen there's a
difference between jiu jitsu
and crazy old Marine
and you're not going to be arm barring
me
when I'm gouging eyes right and so that
was the comment and he kind of like
thought he probably thought like I'd be
like hell yeah because I love the
Marines and I love the military
but I haven't responded to him yet but
I'm going to respond to him and I'm
gonna I'm gonna say hey bro like
actually you're not gonna be gouging
anybody's eyes when you're getting
choked and arm locked because that's
what's really going to happen and you
know Dean always has a good explanation
of like
oh you know hey uh some of the guy I'll
say to Dean like well yeah I would just
like bite your face
and Dean Dean's like yeah cool then I'll
be mad yeah nice you know because then
you make Dean mad or you make a jiu
jitsu guy mad so now when they're
mounted on you
like I'm also gonna bite your face yeah
we had a friend here uh that was a seal
a jiu jitsu guy and he got into a street
fight
and he like was a cross side on a dude
you might remember he got his ear bitten
off like kind of not bitten off but like
if you took if you took a piece of pizza
and like turned it to the side and took
a bite not out of like this truck the
tip of the triangle but like out of the
side it looked like that like just a
bite was gone you know what I'm saying
like a bike was gone of this dude of
this Seal's ear
but now what happened in the fight now
he was pissed oh yeah I mean he just
like annihilated this guy could have
killed him or whatever but
yeah so that self-defense stuff of like
well I'll kick you in the nuts or I'll
uh you know I gouge you or I'll Fish
Hook you no you actually or you may
maybe you will but it's not gonna help
she's not gonna help and the other thing
is like oh well oh jiu jitsu why would
you want to go to the ground in
self-defense don't want to go to the
ground self defense hopefully we don't
have to hopefully just knock a dude out
you know hopefully just you know give
him a nice one two three and the dudes
knock down you move on carry on with
your day yeah but we landed there and
now we're here yeah but all of a sudden
I got you know gang tackled yeah or
tackled by somebody our trip to fell and
now the only way I can handle this
situation is if I know how to get back
off my feet and do Jiu Jitsu unbox
somebody or whatever yeah and I'm a
purple belt Pan Am champ so guess what's
gonna happen yeah yeah I'm gonna do all
that [__] you just said yeah yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be uh not good uh so
yeah that's that's definitely something
to think about have you ever had
how has Jiu Jitsu performed for you in
the streets I mean I've never lost a
street fight
I I'm a witness
what is your go-to move in a street
fight no you're not you've never seen me
fight anybody
I'm a witness oh no I'm not a witness
that's right
dude you know what you're just imagining
how Kick-Ass it would be well that's
what happens though when Glover tells
you about a fight that he had it's like
I'm there like I already imagined it
because I know this moves he's like yeah
I double League the guy ran around him I
laughed at him he tried to chase me that
must be so that's what I was trying to
say with Hannah is that hinners like he
he fails to mention that he's a badass
wrestler dog he's a dope ass boxer yeah
you know what I'm saying he's like how
did you win streets fights I'm like I
never really used Jiu Jitsu I always
like faked double legs and then punch
the [__] out of dudes when they fell to
the oh I'm gonna get double legged and I
punched them and I was like well didn't
even use any Jiu Jitsu there yeah but
but my coach was with with ilio he was
that was his best he was his best
student look on this subject it's like I
said I started off with many truths
exist at the same time
they're both true and they're both exist
at the same time and it's almost
pointless to talk about this what do you
call it a paradox what do you call that
I don't know questions
I do a lot of times when people have a
strong argument for or against their
they look at it my what my brother would
call in a vacuum so they'll take a very
individual thing unchallenged in the
real world kind of a thing and then
a concept no I'm not saying Jiu Jitsu as
a whole and just like how you said Brad
there's so many truths going on in that
but I'm saying a concept and then
they'll challenge you again sometimes a
straw man but sometimes not uh another
in the vacuum concept and then they'll
go to battle but a lot of times
especially um kind of what you were
saying in that debate do you know what
straw man is Pete no
like the worst example explain it in a
nutshell it's like the worst example of
someone's side it's usually like
inaccurate but
um I got it now I understand but either
way like when you talk about a
competitor in Jiu Jitsu and then the
other side would be like oh uh you you
would never pull guard on the street
which is true but then they're
representing that as like their position
I wouldn't say never I wouldn't never
say donkey Garden full Garden Street
yeah and then even that that's not
necessarily true maybe for Jeff and
that's all no because if you jump full
guard you're gonna land straight on the
paper's credit he he did say some things
that you know I think the Jiu Jitsu
Community wanted to hear him say I asked
him if he thought John danaher was the
number one dude in the world right now
I'm like because we all agree on that do
you do you agree with that or are you
gonna say your grandpa
you know and I was like okay do you
think Jiu Jitsu guys who do tournaments
can win street fights and he was like
yes I agree with that well you know I
was like cool that's what that's all I
was saying I was like I don't disagree
with anything he says yeah and see and
then so the conflict really comes when
the the interchangeability of
generalities versus specifics kind of
goes on and that's how it goes yeah look
if someone could always say generally
speaking if someone always could say
that and then when they go specific they
say well specific that's great a lot of
specifics have no place in a general
argument that's great so people don't
understand that so they get this this
way
the way it works you see it happening
all the time write that down peep
generalities are different in specifics
yeah
I always say I'm the I'm one of the
worst people to introduce people to jiu
jitsu because I'm like big and strong
and so if I when I would like introduce
someone to jiu jitsu they'd be like well
that's just because you're big and
strong whoa matter of fact to this day
someone will be like well yeah good role
you're really strong you're big and
strong or whatever and I'm always like
yeah thanks man that's why I lift
but Jeff I think you're like I think
you're the ultimate I live too but yeah
I think you're the ultimate person to
introduce Jiu Jitsu to other people
because you're you are unassuming and
what made me think of that is dude I
can't imagine the fool and how how how
crappy it is when someone sees you and
they're like I'm gonna talk some [__] to
this little skinny white kid right now
oh it happens you know yeah I've been a
witness
[Music]
I know nothing aren't you Mexican though
uh my dad is half Mexican now pretty
much so you are Mexican is it yeah well
my dad you look like a white boy man
he's like half white half Cherokee
Indian so but they would just say
Mexican wait your dad is half white and
half Cherokee Indian yeah is your mom
like my mom's the whitest person ever
she is yeah because damn yeah I'm white
you were white
dude it would look crazy when I'd be
with my grandma people think she like
kidnapping me
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right uh 80cc So speaking of which I
saw you up there this year what did you
think of everything what was your
impression number let me start off by
saying this yeah it's great
bro when I went and saw you when I was
talking about going to see you at the
ADCC trials like that was literally in
like a
what was it in like a hotel back room or
something Hotel Ballroom yeah like a
hotel Ballroom or not a nice hotel
either but just like some shitty hotel
and they put some mats on the floor I
thought it was nice there's like 200
people watching right less than that
less than that yeah that's the people
there there was no way to be watching
yeah actually just people competing and
then people there's people competing and
they're watching the others compete yeah
uh
this one was crazy it was epic there was
15 000 people in a big damn Stadium nice
and the Jiu Jitsu was just freaking nuts
to watch
it was nuts to watch what are you seeing
in the evolution of Jiu Jitsu right now
yeah it's interesting right I have a
very interesting perspective I wish I
could explain it I wish I had the
vocabulary to explain that but like
it's it's remember when you first saw
those first ADCC matches with the Sheik
and they're like
in the boot the drums and the Arab dudes
playing drums in the background and it's
just so it was something so magical you
know it was like being a kid again it
was like it was like all of a sudden Pro
remember when we found out pro wrestling
was fake you know what I'm saying you're
so heartbroken I was and then I found
Abu Dhabi and I was like oh my God it's
not like Pro wrestling's really good
it's real you know like like these dudes
are real real like Dean's a real [__]
Pro like like macho man is like you know
that one that was like Dean Lister
Dean's List there's like a real life
Macho Man you know
so yeah it's just every every year it's
always so special you know you could go
back and watch 80cc 1996. an untrained
eye and watch that [__] and be like wow
that's [__] amazing you know I can't
imagine somebody who just started
Jujitsu last year Watching 80cc and
being like Oh what am I getting myself
into that was crazy you know am I going
to be doing that like whoa It's just
yeah it's it's
I don't know how how people
um don't want to do it what do you think
about the evolution of the game
um like what it looks like now it's a
tough question people ask that one
that's a tough one I don't know like has
it really evolved we're all just going
for neck arms and legs yeah that's true
I was pleasantly surprised the last
couple uh matches in big tournaments
I've been watching because like I'll be
here
and training and like for this is an
example I'm freaking trying to pass
Dean's guard trying to pass uh Wes's
guard whatever which like Echoes go like
we're they spend a lot of time trying to
pass guard
and man sometimes I think dude I just
suck at Jiu Jitsu now I need to freaking
you know like just find a new sport to
go start playing croquet or some [__]
you know like why because you're bored
or no because I suck and I'm like dude I
suck and then we'll go and watch like at
ECC I was like I was watching I was like
that's right and I I'd realize this uh
six months ago I was like oh this is
what Jiu Jitsu looks like more now
people are better their guard is better
their leg attacks are better you can't
dive into stuff the way you could
everyone's just better so it takes more
skill and more time to pass the guard
and as I watched all these matches I'm
like yeah this is it's just it's just a
different game now now there are
Evolutions that are happening right now
that I'm seeing like Pete you were
talking about them some of the other
night they were trying to do like okay
so with the ibgf tournaments that that
were before well they still have them
now it's um
you don't have to be specifically too
good at that many skills you could be
good at two or three positions and hold
the person and win
but now at these tournaments of
submission only or Glover has a tenor
tab system there's an 80cc systems
you're getting penalized for just
holding a guy in one position
so
with nogi you're not gonna be able to
hold anyone down under sweaty so what
what people are doing now is leaning on
the person and making them carry the
weight
and then
on the bottom you're pretty much changed
it's always been like yeah I'm finding
where the evolution is coming in okay
pretty much failing to find that yeah
there's yeah it's a site it's just real
Styles it's always a new one what's new
is old like look at these old Greek guys
like Achilles and Zeus and like those
dudes knew how to Grapple I guarantee
you like who you kidding didn't he come
up with the Achilles lock yeah all that
stuff that makes sense
all that stuff so when did you get off
freaking focused on wrist locks while
we're going down this Rabbit Hole okay
so when
I lived in Brazil I lost to the in the
worlds it was like my fifth mansion and
Oswaldo Oliver he's an old guy Andre gov
just tell this story kind of faster the
Wii is wearing off come on Peter come
live with us and this is the old guy is
the wrist lock Master can I tell your
story stop and then he taught me a
couple wrist locks
and then when I hurt my back I couldn't
do arm bars anymore so if you grab the
arm you gotta spin all the way around
like Glover you see when he grabs her
arm he's jumping around I just I focus
on the wrist and elbow and I snap it and
if it works it works if it doesn't work
I use it to pass a guard you can see
like Kade Rotolo he used the wristline
against Mika galvao he starts snapping
his wrist you highlighted that yeah Mika
pulls out and then he he starts coming
around circling goes back to the center
goes again Mika hides his wrist gives
him the pass and he takes it away and
then he stuck his leg in exactly and I
only had these videos out for a couple
years now mind you I came up with
stocked the world when I was living with
Glover we're sitting over there in
National City over here working with you
guys and I was so pissed I was like [__]
the world
I'm like no
restock the world like Whistler Wu-Tang
like
like yeah Glover's like [__] you Pete
like I need something like that come up
with something like that for me and like
it just took off I you know I started um
wtw it stands for a lot of things ptg
stands for pasta guard pasta guac
you know pass the guard pressure the
guard pressure the garden pray to
whomever you choose there's a lot of
things
and uh man doing Jitsu Glover is fun and
I can honestly say like
I I didn't I don't have like you had
bill or you had Dean I had Carlson he
passed away so it's like my guy is gone
so thank God I end up in the best rooms
with the best people that love Jiu Jitsu
and lately I've been um somehow I ended
up with the Rotolo Brothers I'm with
them every day we do this foundations
training you know we do like Spears like
this and all this stuff is fixing them
but I get to be around them so it's
fixing me and and the guys are like
living in Hawaii where I got hurt
initially
and so it just it's all coming full
circle and that's what's so cool about
martial arts is
comes around full circle last time we
were here I don't even was there a
jockled podcast when we were here years
ago like I don't even know it's only
been around for about six years seven
years seven years yeah it's so weird so
it just it's all coming full circle and
I think the more you love Jiu Jitsu the
more to love you and and Jeff and I have
made how many videos I mean like I
showed up to BJJ Fanatics I made wrist
lock the world danaher's the one that
actually got me that job like I don't
know him so well but he gets a kick out
of me and they call me up Bernardo calls
me up and I show up there and I seen
that at Jeff Glover DVD in their own
collection it was with like another
company yeah I forgot their name I
thought I thought Pete was full of [__]
I was like dude peaceful I'm like Glover
what am I supposed to do here I've been
here like [__] about what just
everything he said I was like this dude
just he lies about all kinds of he
always thinks I'm a scammer because he
hasn't met like I'm sustained in Greek
he's used to like
Mexican and then I met the owner like
you've never met me before he thinks I'm
a scary wait this is BJJ Fanatics yeah
yeah and when when the guy he was like
oh yeah just passively he's like yeah
Dean gets these blah blah blah checks
every month I was like what like I might
go over get your ass over here [__] you
Pete I'm not leaving San Diego yeah I
was like I don't want to go out there
Boston it's cold out there he's like
it's cold out I'm like all right Glover
and then they get on there and [__] and
then Glover always we always try to top
each other that's what's really cool
like so like what we do is we hang out
extremely a lot and then we disband and
we try to like come up who can come up
with more stuff but I got hurt before
him so like
like the people that like it they gotta
really be into it to know me they gotta
pretty much be into it to know him they
don't even got to be into it to know Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan like he's the one that
probably like he's like the Scotty now
he's like ever he's like
you know what I mean Scotty was like
that like for this us as kids but now
you got like Joe Rogan
and we're all friends
Eddie Bravo Eddie's our good friend like
shoot like
he does the other half guard you know he
what do they call him the lockdown
so like Nemesis lover and Eddie they're
kind of like
they're from the same planet or
something I don't know but he's my other
good buddy yeah shoot he gets a kick out
and we're all we're all connected and
Joe Rogan
hey thanks a lot because
every Jitsu School in the world should
thank that guy for sure period right
yeah for sure spreading the word Joey
Diaz I gave him that class
changed his life he put the video out
and um shout out to him too
because he's um
and he knows everything about martial
arts believe it or not he did kung fu
and all that stuff and I looked at him I
said you know what you need to get on
the match brother and I talked to him at
least once a week like when my mom was
on hospice we call up Joey he thinks
he's real he's like yeah it's your uncle
for your mom said it's weird it's like
we're really related and uh
cool dude he loves Glover I know
everyone's uh
yes or no like dude these guys are
calling me
my mom's sick my mom just passed away a
few weeks ago look
Eddie Bravo calls up every night plays
music for her crazy that's crazy I mean
he's he calls me up uh do you guys
remember the Eddie Bravo video that was
cribs uh oh yeah I'm in that video I
tried to find it on it's not on YouTube
but we gotta get the I gotta do that I
got it at home it's called The Twister
I'm on the Easter egg so if you like go
up down left right up down left right
yeah so it was on that DVD so that's why
I have it that's why I must have it but
I don't even have it and you can Z
player anymore yeah there's a way um you
press like up down left right they're
called Easter eggs Scotty's brother Cade
who's like a computer genius this guy
put it in there so when he put the
little code in and I pop up and
and Eddie Bravo yeah he's shoot just
regular dude like us and then next thing
you know he's he's another one like
shoot 10th Planet they're everywhere
yeah they're nice to Glover and I like
we've been doing how many 10 Planet
schools teaching Center like there's a
it's one thing that's cool like uh you
know back in the day it seemed like
there was more animosity and maybe there
still is but between Jiu Jitsu schools
and all that stuff
it seems like that's not so definitely
what let me say it doesn't even seem
they're definitely not that as much
animosity as there used to be between or
maybe it's just between all the people
we know we're in their systems you know
like they have moves named after Glover
they have wrist socks after me I'm sure
that moves when you're part of someone's
system
there's no denying it you know like
Glover's got like they they have like
moves and they have a system of moves
like they have like
how can you not be friends with you're
in their system yeah geez well right on
so what so if guys are looking to follow
you guys now want to do a Sim where how
do they get to do a uh Jeff Glover
seminar in their Academy I have the same
booking agent that Dean has it's a guy
named Dave Herbert so where do they go
like is it a writers International it's
a it's a it's a you know booking agency
where he does uh seminars for striking
people and whatever Dean came to my
tournament introduced me to the guy
about it being bada boom he's booking
all of our seminars for us and making it
easy so Strikers International on
Instagram is the guy's page
and or you could just contact me on
Instagram and we can book seminars and
flat rate and all that stuff and your
and your Instagram is at Jeff Jeff
Glover BJJ that's right you guys are
both you already mentioned this BJJ
Fanatics which is a compilation website
of all the best guys in the world making
videos
instructional videos both you guys are
on there we have a lot of content most
of the people have a couple of videos
Jeff and I are there a lot like we have
between the both of us who made probably
40 videos in the past year and a half
and um I'm I just started working with
Strikers International too
so you could contact them or you could
find us do to remind me after this let's
talk to the boys at BJJ Fanatics and put
like a special on when this comes out
you know what I'm saying so maybe people
could buy like a like 10 of your videos
or something you know there's always
like even if you buy one video every
little bit helps you know Jeff and I
actually taught we taught a lot of
classes we remember we talked we talked
to Marine together and stuff yeah Joel
Hoffman remember Colonel Joe yeah so
there's no discrimination we're here to
teach you know and if you're watching
this years from now on Instagram maybe
it doesn't even exist who knows you can
always find us Pete the Greek you know
what I mean Jiu Jitsu and there's Jeff
Glover Jitsu and Jocko you can find us
if you want us
all these guys I mean you're a Pete the
Greek wrist lock the world is that one
big thing on Instagram is it that whole
thing or is it just the whole thing is
there's some other Pete the Greek guy
that's kind of kind of fake he's you're
you're BJJ School is called riobjj.com
um well let's see what's the and that's
also where you can get t-shirts or
whatever just go to
wristlockthetheworld.com I bought that
one it brings you to everything
um on my instagram.com I put a I put a
link tree so you can set up all your
links and like I said if Instagram's not
around in the future you can always find
us you know we do Jiu Jitsu wherever
they're Jiu Jitsu you'll find Glover in
the Greek
right on and and there were Toler
Brothers I want to give a shout out to
them because my mom just passed away I
was feeling down Jeff all the way in
Santa Barbara and and these kids like
I don't know I have a good connection
with them and
and they're about the only ones as cool
as watching Glover as far as I'm
concerned because most of the matches I
fall asleep and these guys I get the
they're the only ones that remind me of
Glovers let's go man I just want to add
it when his mom died I I showed up no
Glover's great my mom's there
[__] I was there for that okay
oh the glove was in Santa Barbara no I
came I came to be with you oh no my mom
looked at me she was I'm tired I say I'm
tired anyone's listening thinks I'm a
bad friend
she's from Chicago that's a good and my
grandma's Leona from these are all like
pizza people my grandma's the first
woman in Chicago to have a a restaurant
a business
so uh Hey shout out to shy Town dude
shout out you know what I mean right on
awesome Echo you got anything else oh
yeah a couple things Sandy Beach okay
that's real sandy beach is on Oahu belt
by the way it's not in Hilo they might
no they took me there yeah oh yeah hey
we're gonna go oh yeah we're gonna go uh
training oh yeah so it's very notorious
for the short break
short pounds sure if you will I'm saying
in this scenario it's probably
appropriate short pound oh yeah and it's
super common for guys to get injured
there and so you know they they post
signs and all that stuff but you know
Pete the Greek ain't reading those signs
no way when you're going with the boys
yeah so you got to watch out though for
that that's it's notorious for that kind
of stuff first or the short break yes
what Spirit watch out for uh Sandy Beach
Spirit secondly I think I figured out
maybe five ten percent of your
whole thing who Jeff Glover did you
pointing out Jeff Jeff Glover
you like you
the original structure if you will of
Jiu Jitsu and you were like oh wait
there's more stuff underneath the hood
here so you just like you know how you
ever buy like a remote control car and
be like okay cool and you take it apart
and you see the motor and you see how
everything works you're like okay you
take the original structure of jujitsu
and then when you roll you sort of take
it apart like you do stuff that you're
not supposed to do you let them out just
see what happens see let me take off
those Wheels okay reverse engineering in
a way in a way but more and more it's
like a it's a form of experimentation so
it's like when you do that you start to
see little connections like oh this
piece doesn't have to fit here it can
fit like over here I dig that and the
reason we're one of the days that uh
you're teaching and I figured that out
is you did this drill that I never been
a part of before you were like okay get
into whatever position Mount right and
you'll be and then you'll just call out
another position or submission and
you'll be like get there as quick as you
can and some people would be like oh I
gotta go here some people they don't
even know how to get there they'll just
sort of
climb over and for which it won't really
work but it's part of the the drill you
know if you find the shortest path there
I was just gonna say exactly right find
the shortest path but
it's a test is a test to see who
stumbles through that one and just you
know yeah makes the 15 moves that could
have been two but I felt it though
because when you were like oh yeah mount
you we're in Mount and you said go to
the knee bar and I was like I know the
drill so I'm not just gonna just go to
the knee bar like the way you kind of
can't really do it I gotta go to another
step first it's like okay I go half
guard then the knee bar from you know
Dean's knee bar or whatever and I
remember you watching and being like
kind of looking as if just to kind of a
little bit disgusting no no the opposite
it was kind of approved and not to say
that that was such a great performance
of the drill it was more like this is
how I felt I don't know I I couldn't
read his mind I just read his look where
it was like the way I felt at that time
was like this is the purpose of this
drill is to like don't think of it in
terms of like oh I know what an arm bar
is let me just go there it's more like
figure out the quickest way and you'll
probably figure out that there's quicker
ways than how you do it when you really
roll or there's actually ways to get
there even though it doesn't seem right
there available at the time see I'm
saying and then so I started thinking
back and not to say I did this all in
one day or nothing like that but then if
you think back to like a lot of your
stuff like you'll do a DARS choke choke
when they're passing your guard and I'm
like uh that's not usually where they
teach the darts joke is it it's usually
from a very specific you know number of
positions and then you if you look like
his match against um this was in 2009.
uh it was you you win against Joel first
and then Bill the girl Cooper I forget
who you went with first this is like one
of the personal Martinez I think that
was the day two yeah you know him yeah
he's a good dude but it was a random
tournament in Del Mar yeah okay and that
was the first time I think I've seen you
in real life and
I was watching you do stuff I was like
wait he's like doing a lot of creative
stuff yeah it's creative but it's like
you're violating a bunch of rules just
so you can Implement something that
works by the way
and then when it's a good Demon the the
best demonstration of that that I
remember is you against Bill the girl
when you guys were both doing it God
yeah we closed out several uh pro events
where we were like in the finals against
each other yeah and he was like this is
my little brother you know yeah we would
just like let's let's put on a dope show
yes it's gonna be a fixed match but it's
gonna be so cool that people don't mind
watching a fixed oh yeah it was yeah it
was crazy yeah just like uh it's like
why I talk about like musicians and how
a musician that's really like uh Jimmy
Page you know he played like as a studio
musician for for decades like as a as
like a teenager he was playing as a
studio musician I play these exact notes
at this exact time and he so got so
disciplined and so good that when he got
to Led Zeppelin he's like oh watch this
I'm gonna play a note here with a
freaking violin thing whatever that
thing is called and I'm gonna start
playing a guitar in a totally different
way and it's gonna work and it's gonna
sound awesome that's to me that's like
Jeff Glover on the math of Justice damn
got compared to Led Zeppelin hell yeah
you did uh right on fellas appreciate
you guys coming down I'm looking forward
to taking class this afternoon yeah
that's all I got yeah thanks fellas
thank you boys thank you we out
and with that Jeff Glover and Pete the
Greek have left the building yeah
little Jiu Jitsu talk today yeah
uh you know for me
from my perspective it's kind of
interesting to be like last night
thinking I was gonna do this podcast
talking about Jiu Jitsu with Jeffy
and Pete and it was kind of
it's kind of is a lot different right A
lot of times I'm reading from a book
yeah or I'm you know we're talking to
someone that's been through some
horrific things
and it's usually pretty heavy
emotionally heavy yeah so it was kind of
I must say it was kind of relaxing yeah
what lighthearted to come in and just be
like oh we're gonna talk about Jujitsu
with with Jeff and Pete who are both you
know like super nice and chill so there
you go uh Jiu Jitsu Jiu Jitsu it was fun
so my I came in this the Jiu-Jitsu scene
in 2005 and which was in kind of the
beginning of the height of of Jeff
Glover
so I saw Bill the grill Jeff Glover like
these guys or whatever so it is
interesting to hear like his version of
that timeline yeah and so I was like oh
that's when that's when I came on the
scene grappler's Quest Best of the West
freaking the the world submission
Grappling Championships it was like
grappler's Quest you were a little
behind when there used to be
used to be some some really interesting
tournaments good tournaments but yeah
sounds like there's a there's a series
of tournaments that the tournaments
you're talking came after
there was like what was that one like
the Olympics of grappling or something
like this
grappling games
so I think that one Faded by the time
new there was a place in La called
neutral grounds that was old school back
in the day I mean we're talking like
there'd be 50 people there yeah in a
cage yeah like with the grappling
matches were in a cage
Dean Lister had a tournament or a match
against a guy there
and Dean got him in some kind of hold so
I'm gonna choke hold but like a oh no
Rico Rodriguez got this guy but the guy
didn't tap
and he like when did ref stopped it or
whatever the dude like didn't get up for
a while like they were thinking this guy
might not be alive yeah there was some
crazy stuff but a little bit Rogue
back in those days yeah yeah it's crazy
how how different it is now it is the
popularity of Jiu Jitsu is is awesome to
see and Jujitsu is fun yes sir and that
the way that Jeff Glover rolls makes it
even more fun watching him roll make it
fun yeah he he's like the ideal of
um
like exploratory and then what you gain
like when you or I mean him as the
example like what he has gained from
exploring Jiu Jitsu in that way so much
is that's what makes it so like you're
not used to that kind of stuff and so it
comes off as so amazing and it's it's
available to most people like that but
it's hard to like get in that mindset
because he does it straight up during
competitions yeah like watch like
metamoras I think it was like four yeah
a secret match oh yeah so he's the
announcer by the way you know like a
secret match and it's Barry Yoshida yeah
who just it was in the Hall of Fame of
ADCC by the way
Barry Yoshida versus somebody it's a
secret right it's like a surprise and
they're like do you have Glover the
announcer gets off takes off a suit and
goes and goes
and boom exploratory Jiu Jitsu donkey
guard all this unorthodox stuff but it's
like it's by Design you know man yeah
it's interesting too because they're
like they live um kind of for lack of
better term like a jiu jitsu Nomad style
yeah right where they go around everyone
knows them they know everybody Kung Fu
walking to Earth yeah
it's crazy that for like five years
at Victory MMA and fitness look we have
Dean Lister teaching like which is
insane just to think you can learn all
the stuff from Dean Lish yep
but for five years we had Dean list
which is as good as it's gonna get and
Jeff Glover it was crazy yeah it's like
every day was just it was crazy it was
epic one time I rolled with Jeff and I
wrote him many many times and so the
thing I remember about or the thing that
that makes this very memorable is this
was a whole day I rolled with them like
a bunch of times
where where Rollings being all he's
keeping it play for or whatever and then
he switched and kept it real because if
you don't know there's two two modes
keeping it playful and keeping it real
that Tanner he don't Gracie made up
those terms by the way but
he he switches over to keeping it real
and busts out some wrestling on me yeah
and I I don't mean on me because I'm so
good and so that's why I'm not saying
that I'm saying because I outweighed him
by a lot and he just put it on me
another notable thing is earlier
okay so I like Kimora especially on
smaller guys
he saw the Kimura coming he gave me the
Kimura and he reached behind his back
and just held his arms as if to be like
I'm giving you this Kimura but it's your
job to finish it couldn't finish it I
was like bro see that's and it's not
like I'm smaller than him where it's
like I'm bigger like the the chance of
me finishing it is gonna be higher than
you know maybe a smaller guy still does
it but that's that exploratory process
that's gonna allow him to understand all
his available maneuver Maneuvers when
your hand is already behind your back uh
he has that we talked about it but that
level of confidence like an insane level
of confidence you know when you watch
Dean Lister with foot locks he has that
specifically with full locks like he'll
there's been tournaments where Dean
would like stick his feet out like go
ahead please try and unlock me but man
dude Glover has that from a positional
attitude like he doesn't care what
position someone gets he's gonna
so
um awesome stuff thanks for those guys
for coming on uh support the podcast
you want to support the podcast you got
to support yourself hopefully you're
gonna start training Jiu Jitsu we can't
even start to you can't even start to
explain how much Jitsu is going to help
you in your life
you gotta you gotta you gotta say listen
I you gotta have faith in what we're
saying right because I can't explain it
Echo can't explain it You Gotta Have A
Little Bit of Faith just to go try it
and my recommendation is you do Jiu
Jitsu until you submit someone yeah
that's the I made that I did make that
up I'll take credit for it you do Jiu
Jitsu until you submit someone once you
submit someone if you decide oh I don't
like this yeah did you could move on
that's probably not gonna happen though
because once you submit somebody you're
like it's like a drug yeah right yeah
and you know what else is like a drug if
you have the right attitude is getting
submitted is like damn how'd that happen
yeah how'd that happen you know so it
can be a horrible thing but uh start
training Jiu Jitsu if you're gonna do in
Jiu Jitsu you're gonna need to fuel that
Jiu Jitsu get yourself some Jocko if
you'll clean fuel clean energy good for
you making stuff that's literally good
for you uh go to jockofuel.com you can
get these drinks God they're good you
can get these drinks we hey if you tried
the drinks like six months ago
the Jocko go drinks you may not have
liked the taste you might have been like
but we because of that because that
feedback we reformulated the flavors and
now they freaking taste delicious
so that's that Mulk he probably just are
down with that one if you're drinking
milk you're drinking milk I mean Mulk is
a savior to your to your body oh yeah
it's a savior to your body it's gonna
you get that Mulk hitter it's also a
mental savior because you just got done
eating a eating a wagyu rib eye
sure you know what I'm saying like this
is top of Top Dog yep right you just get
done eating them just a beautiful rib
eye even though it was delicious you
still get done you want a little
something sweet sure it's possible it's
possible so that's where you got that
milk train get on the Moke we're gonna
be happy so you get that you get the
drinks at Wawa you get the protein the
ready to drink protein drinks at Wawa
right now we're making them as fast as
we can we're selling them way faster
than we predicted uh the pro the ready
to drink milk so you can now go into
Wawa you can go into Vitamin Shop you
can just go oh cool I want a drink right
now yeah I need 30 grams of protein
right now I'm going catabolic it's an
emergency scenario boom ready to drink
we're making them as fast as we can and
we'll we'll keep making them so Wawa
Vitamin Shoppe taco fuel.com
come and get it also if you're doing jiu
jitsu you're gonna need a jiu jitsu gi
ghee no ghee you might need a rash guard
we got some no gee shorts coming we got
all kinds of stuff that's at
originusa.com all the stuff's made in
America hunt gear done out
jeans
boots I mean this is what you need to
live
you need you need a ghee
you need Jiu Jitsu shorts and rash guard
you need jeans you need a t-shirt you
need a hoodie we got you covered yeah
you need boots we got your coverage
originusa.com and this stuff is Made In
America which is the
critical
the critical part of this because
there's companies out there right now
that are going to try to sell you
something they got a brand right yeah
they got a brand making a brand oh our
brand is whatever
and what they do is they come up with
some ideas and they design it and
there's four people working there seven
people working there
and you know what they they design it
and then they order it from China and
then over in a sweatshop some slave
labor makes it sends it to here they
sell it
and they keep that money and they go
cool we made money let's do it again
that's not what we're doing we're making
it in America so we do design it but
then we bring the designs to the factory
our factories here in Maine and North
Carolina and we make it Americans make
this stuff
and you'd think oh it must be seven
times more expensive than the slave
labor no it's not it's not
and you're you're investing in America
so originusa.com go get some get
whatever you need yeah it's true also
Jack was a store it's called Jocko store
so we can get discipline equals Freedom
stuff t-shirts and hats and hoodies
merch if you will a little bit better
quality than just random merch by the
way
also we got the shirt Locker which is
the new shirt new shirt design every
month
the good they're creative they're fun
you know some controversial
and there's been some controversial ones
controversy but the ones I come up with
seem to be more controversial in a way
yeah
my specific designs yeah well your
controversially minded person from time
to time we'll say that but you know
overall great great feedback uh check
that out go to jockostore.com you can
look at everything if you like something
hey man get something uh subscribe to
the podcast you already know that
don't forget about unraveling don't
forget about the warrior kid podcast I
know I call some I'm sorry
working on that latest Warrior Kid book
we'll get it to you Jocko
underground.com we have that in case we
get banned for whatever reason who knows
maybe they don't like uh people from
Chicago named Pete the Greek and they're
like hey we're getting rid of this guy
so eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month if you want to get on board with
that we appreciate it if you can't
afford it no big deal email assistance
Jocko underground.com we got a YouTube
channel origin USA has a YouTube channel
we got psychological warfare we got
flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Myers gig
we got a bunch of books only cry for the
living by Holly McKay all the books I've
written final spin leadership strategy
and tactics Field Manual the kids but
get the get the kids you know the kids
books please please
do that Mikey and the dragons were the
way the warrior kids series
I have a company called Echelon front
the leadership consultancy we saw
problems through leadership
so if you want to get involved in that
echelonfront.com we have uh Live Events
they sell out so if you want to come go
check out events there
excellentfront.com or if you need
long-term help
go there put in the request and if you
want to help service members active and
retire you want to help their families
you want to help the gold star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or you want to get involved
go to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
if you want to help vets by getting them
out into the Wilderness so they can
ReDiscover their soul
go to heroesandhorses.org
and once again if you want to follow
Jeff and Pete Pete is on Instagram at
Pete the Greek wrist locked the world
he's also at wristlocktheworld.com
uh
Jeff is on Instagram at Jeff Glover BJJ
and listen both these guys have a bunch
of instructional videos on
bjjfanatics.com
and I know the guys from bjjfanatics.com
Bernardo and and Michael the guys that
run it the guys that own it it's they're
they're doing a great job of putting out
great content so check out videos if you
if you want to check these guys out if
you want to learn from them if you want
to learn from anybody you can go to
bjjfanatics.com and you're probably
gonna find that champion that you want
to learn from on there so go check that
out if you want to learn the basics of
Jiu Jitsu there's basic videos on there
so check that out
as for us
and by us I mean Echo Charles and myself
we're also on this the the interwebs
we're on Twitter I've been getting a
little bit back into Twitter since it
seems like it might be getting picked up
by Elon Musk
who may or probably going to do a better
job of not censoring people
which makes you kind of question the
whole gig
um so Twitter
the Graham Facebook were on their Echoes
at Echo Charles I'm at Jocko willink of
course you gotta watch out for that
algorithm
because it will catch you and the reason
I know it'll catch you is because where
I cheat
when I go in my ice bath I kind of cheat
when I go on my ice bath I will look at
the Instagram or some some social media
when I'm in there and time just goes by
you're like oh it's been six minutes how
did that happen oh because my brain was
captured yeah yeah sedated so that's a
good rule of thumb you can only look at
social media when you're in some
uncomfortable scenario like get into a
wall squat
and as long as you can hold it you can
scroll yeah you know you get seven
minutes cool you know you know what I'm
saying yeah go could you hang off a
pull-up bar no because you need your
hand to scroll maybe you could what
others what's another crappy position to
getting ice bath for sure
talking to you ice bath yeah you could
sit there and have to talk to me you're
a little frustrated today
what was the frustration about I wasn't
frustrated too no no it was yesterday no
you were Road raging I wasn't worried
raging today that was yesterday Hawaiian
because you because you took it upon
yourself to interrupt me in the morning
by the way
in the middle of my workout with some
nonsense if
do you resp but you responded during a
workout yeah is that a good move you
think no no I I know now yeah no bad
move terrible what was it what was the
trigger statement that I made I don't
know I'd have to go through the thread
but there because there was a few
multiple yep so I made multiple comments
it's true true story then you have to
come here and sit there and talk to me
for a long period of time so I should
have been scrolling social media during
that time mental anguish check
[Music]
all right well watch out for that
algorithm unless I'm you know verbally
abusing you then it could be a nice
little Escape see that's what you need
you need a little escape from my uh uh
from my abusive personality you know
apparently the world makes sense you're
going to train after this well I don't
know 50 50. I have another engagement
today okay I have you knew we were doing
this today yeah I have my clothes and
everything okay
all right okay well hey that's on you
know that's on the world you know I
guess that's not your fault see your
whole tone right now yeah see that's
what that's part of what I'm talking
about it's part of it it's part of it
yeah it is yes Jack all right well once
again
thanks to Jeff and Pete for coming down
thanks for what you guys have done for
jiu jitsu always stoked to have you all
around and thanks for helping so many
people out by giving them the gift and
it is a gift of Jiu Jitsu so thanks
fellas and I also want to thank our
service members
from the Army Navy Air Force Marines
Coast Guard
we get to train
Jiu Jitsu because you all protect us
and by the way all of you in the service
if you get a chance
and actually you should make a chance go
find a way to train Jiu Jitsu it's going
to help you in everything that you do
same goes for the rest of our police and
law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics emt's dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders
thanks for protecting us and keeping us
safe so that we can live our lives
and same thing guess what please
please go out and start training Jiu
Jitsu if you don't already it
can save your life
and everyone else out there guess what
I'm going to say the same thing
if you're training Jiu Jitsu right now
cool keep training and if you're not go
find a Jiu Jitsu Academy and go train
jiu jitsu
and until next time this is zeko and
Jocko
out